foreign
welcome to the world of data management
this comprehensive course explores the
foundation of SQL empowering you with
the ability to interact with relational
databases from complex queries and
manage data effectively Additionally you
will dwell into the mongodb occurring as
nosql database to master document based
data storage and retrieval Unleash the
Power of SQL and mongodb and analog
Endless Possibilities in the data
manipulation and storage let's embark on
this transformative journey together if
you're an aspiring data engineer looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
postgraduate program in data engineering
from Purdue University in collaboration
with IBM should be your right choice for
more details use the link in the
description box below with that in mind
over to our training experts there is no
business online that would not benefit
from using a database whether you are
running a small startup or a billion
dollar company not only are they most
common and efficient way of storing data
but they also form the foundation of
business intelligence and information
management today and if you want to
communicate with these databases you
must learn SQL SQL are often referred to
as SQL by many as considered as one of
the oldest languages in technology
domain which is used to design build and
maintain database applications tailored
to specific needs of the client's
business requirements some popular and
widely used SQL databases are MySQL
Microsoft SQL Server Oracle database and
postgradu SQL SQL developers are high in
demand with companies like Microsoft
cognizant meta Accenture IBM entity data
and many other Tech genes hiring SQL
developers with an average salary of
seventy two thousand dollars and going
as high as hundred and thousand dollars
per year SQL is unquestionably one of
the first steps towards a career
involving data crunching and learning it
will add Great Value to your array of
skills which requires little to almost
no coding knowledge will SQL ever be
replaced anytime soon well probably not
SQL is here to stay and will continue to
be the go to query language for many
years to come first we will understand
who is a SQL Developer SQL Developer is
a person who is accountable in creating
and managing huge data assets of a
company
in other terms SQL Developer is a person
who can develop SQL databases as well as
write-in test code let's understand this
with the help of an example let's say we
want to search a particular product on
Amazon website and Amazon has stored all
its data about products in a database
now we will write the product name in
the search bar and when we click on the
search button it will run a SQL query
that fetches all the information about
the product and displays us on the
website so this is the basic task done
by a SQL Developer
now we will understand the
responsibilities of osql developer all
databases have a structure and logic
behind how data is stored and retrieved
a SQL Developer designs the database
accordingly for businesses that is
called database modeling after the
database is created and deployed it's
the SQL Developer who is responsible for
fixing the general issues of the
database
escrow developer should be well versed
with structured query language to create
optimized SQL queries and refines the
existing ones to extract information
from the database
SQL developers run several diagnostic
tests to keep a check on the server and
the database in order to understand how
to organize company's data SQL
developers must communicate with
tactical and non-technical persons from
the business and SQL Developer also
gathers client requirements and
identifies the features that the
database owners want
as data is an asset to a company SQL
developers backup and restore data for
the clients they also perform tasks like
data management and data migration that
is if a company has stored all its data
on a local storage and now it pawn its
data to be stored in a cloud storage so
the safe transmission of the data from
local storage to cloud storage is known
as data migration and that is done by
the SQL developers after knowing the
responsibilities now we should look for
skill set required to be a good SQL
Developer
one should have a good knowledge of SQL
commands functions joints and procedures
let's have a look at few commands such
as create drop alter and truncate these
commands come under data definition
language we also have insert update and
delete commands these commands come
under data manipulation language we have
Grant and before commands these commands
come under data control language we also
have Commit rollback and save point
commands these come under transaction
control language these are the basic
commands a SQL Developer should be
familiar with and a SQL Developer may
have a little command on any one
programming language you don't have to
be expert in programming all you need is
how to interface between application and
your database for example you are using
MySQL and your web application is based
on PHP then you should know how to
connect your application to the database
and how to issue queries
how to fetch results and then how to
display it to the users
one should have a good understanding of
various database Management systems such
as MySQL Microsoft Access Oracle post
way SQL dbase Fox Pro SQL Lite IBM db2
LibreOffice base mariadb and Microsoft
SQL Server one should know integration
of databases with data visualization
software such as power bi and Tableau
which helps businesses to make better
decisions and give you an add-on as a
SQL Developer one should develop
critical thinking and problem solving
skills to create optimized queries
now we'll see how a SQL Developer is
compensated in both United States and
India
in the United States SQL developers grow
an average salary of dollar 72 282 per
annum in India the average salary of a
SQL Developer is rupees 4 lakh 49532.
now we'll see how person can become a
good SQL Developer for that one should
have a good command on structured query
language and know how to interact with
database management system and can issue
queries to get the desired result
earning industry recognized SQL
Developer certifications such as
Microsoft certified professional
developer mcpd or Oracle PL SQL
Developer certified associate which
usually require a passing score on an
exam
and it's important to accumulate as much
practical experience as possible start
by designing creating and querying small
databases connected with your hobbies
and interests for example your favorite
music videos or your personal finances
this will enable you to gain experience
test your knowledge and build your
project portfolio which will be highly
beneficial when you start applying for
your first full-time position
now we will see some major companies
recruiting SQL developers first we have
the multinational Financial Services
Corporation American Express followed by
the multinational Professional Services
Network ernstein young we also have the
messaging company WhatsApp then we have
the e-commerce giant Amazon as well as
the technology and Computer Solutions
company Dell finally in a list of
companies we have the multinational
technology company Google have you ever
wondered how this big e-commerce
companies manage their tons of data that
keeps updating every second and these
data sets keep on updating in the
databases to perform operations on this
data they should have a conceptual
understanding of these databases and
this is done by understanding ear
diagrams of the databases so let's
understand what 10 year diagram is
an entity relationship diagram
describes the relationship of entities
that needs to be stored in a database ER
diagram is mainly a structural design
for the database it is a framework made
using specialized symbols to define the
relationship between entities ear
diagrams are created based on the three
main components entities attributes
relationships let's understand the use
of ER diagram with the help of a real
world example
here a school needs all its Student
Records to be stored digitally so they
approach an I.T company to do so a
person from the company will meet the
school authorities not all their
requirements describe them in the form
of ER diagram
and get it cross-checked by the school
authorities as the school authorities
approve the ear diagram the database
Engineers would carry further
implementation
let's have a view of an ear diagram
the following diagram showcases two
entities student and course and the
relationship the relationship described
between student and course is many to
many as a course can be opted by several
students and a student can opt for more
than one course here student is the
entity and it possesses the attributes
that is student ID student name and
student age and the course entity has
attributes such as core Smiley and
course name
now we have an understanding of ER
diagram let us see why it has been so
popular
The Logical structure of the database
provided by ear diagram communicates the
landscape of business to different teams
in the company which is eventually
needed to support the business
ear diagram is a GUI representation of
The Logical structure of a database
which gives a better understanding of
the information to be stored in a
database
database designers can use ER diagrams
as a blueprint which reduces complexity
and helps them save time to build
databases quickly ear diagrams helps you
identify the entities that exist in a
system and the relationships between
those entities
after knowing its uses now we should get
familiar with the symbols used in ear
diagram
the rectangle symbol represents the
entities oval symbol represents
attributes a rectangle embedded in a
rectangle represents a weak entity a
dashed oval represents a derived
attribute a diamond symbol represents a
relationship among entities double all
symbol represents multi-valued
attributes now we should dive in and
learn about the components of ER diagram
there are three main components of Air
diagram entity attribute
and relationship
entities have weak entity attributes are
further classified into key attribute
composite attribute multi-valued
attribute and derived attribute
relationships are also classified into
one-to-one relationships one to many
relationships many to one relationships
and many to many relationships
let's understand these components of
rear diagram
starting with entities
an entity can be either a living or a
non-living component an entity is
showcased as a rectangle in an ear
diagram let's understand this with the
help of an ER diagram here both student
and course are in rectangular shape and
are called entities and they represent
the relationship study in a dimension
let's transition to weak entity
an entity that makes Airlines over
another entity is called a weak entity
the weak entity is showcased as a double
rectangle in ER diagram
in the example below the school is a
strong entity because it has a primary
key attribute School number unlike the
school the classroom is a weak entity
because it does not have any primary key
and the room number attribute here acts
only as a discriminator and node or
primary key
now let us know about attributes
attribute an attribute exhibits the
properties of an entity an attribute is
Illustrated with an oval shape in an ER
diagram in the example below student is
an entity and the properties of student
such as address age name and row number
are called its attributes
let's see our first classification under
attribute that is key attribute the key
attribute uniquely identifies an entity
from an entity set the text of a key
attribute is underlined in the example
below we have a student entity and it
has attributes name address row number
and age but here roll number can
uniquely identify a student from a set
of students that's why it is termed as a
key attribute now we will see composite
attribute
an attribute that is composed of several
other attributes is known as a composite
attribute an oval showcases the
composite attribute and the composite
attribute over is further connected with
other roles in the example below we can
see an attribute name
which can have further supports such as
first name middle name and last name
these attributes with further
classification is known as composite
attribute now let's have a look at
multi-valued attribute an attribute that
can possess more than one value are
called multi-value attributes these are
represented as double old shape
in the example below the student entity
has attributes phone number roll number
name and age out of these attributes
phone number can have more than one
entry and the attribute with more than
one value is called multi-valued
attribute
let's see derived attribute an attribute
that can be derived from other
attributes of the entity is known as a
derived attribute in the ER diagram the
derived attribute is represented by
dashed over and in the example below
student entity has both date of birth
and age as attributes here age is a
derived attribute as it can be derived
by subtracting current date from the
student date of birth
now after knowing attributes let's
understand relationship in ER diagram a
relationship is showcased by the diamond
shape in the ear diagram it depicts the
relationship between two entities in the
below example student study course here
both student and course are entities and
studies the relationship between them
now let's go through the type of
relationship
first is one-to-one relationship when a
single element of an entity is
associated with a single element of
another entity this is called one-to-one
relationship
in the example below we have student and
identification card as entities we can
see a student has only one
identification card and an
identification card is given to one
student it represents a one-to-one
relationship
let's see the second one when too many
relationship when a single element of an
entity is associated with more than one
element of another entity is called when
too many relationship in the below
example a customer can place many orders
but a particular order cannot be placed
by many customers
now we will have a look at many to one
relationship when more than one element
of an entity is related to a single
element of another entity it is called
many to one relationship for example
students have to opt for a single course
but a course can be obtained by number
of students let's see many to many
relationship when more than one element
of an entity is associated with more
than one element of another entity is
called many to many relationship
for example an employee can be assigned
to many projects and many employees can
be assigned to a particular project
now after having an understanding of PR
diagram let us know the points to keep
in mind while creating the ear diagram
first identify all the entities in the
system embed all the entities in a
rectangular shape and label them
appropriately this could be a customer a
manager an order an invoice a schedule
Etc
identify relationships between entities
and connect them using a diamond in the
middle illustrating the relationship do
not connect relationships
connect attributes with entities and
label them appropriately and the
attribute should be in our chip assure
that each entity only appears a single
time and eradicate any redundant
entities or relationships in the ear
diagram make sure your ER diagram
supports all the data provided to design
the database make effective use of
colors to highlight key areas in new
diagrams
how to install MySQL and Ubuntu but
before we begin if you are an aspiring
data analyst then I have the perfect
cause for you we have the professional
certificate program in data analytics
both your carrier over this data
analytics program in partnership with
Purdue University and in collaboration
with IBM which features master classes
and follows an applied learning model
with real-time projects and business
case studies now that we have a clear
understanding of the pgp data analytics
certification with simply learn in
collaboration with IBM from Purdue
University we will get started with our
tutorial for today's session so now
we're on the Ubuntu operating system
let's quickly start our terminal the
shortcut key for that is control alt D
so now we have the terminal opened so we
might have to run a few couple of
commands
so the first one would be pseudo apt
upgrade or update
I will ask for the host password
now you have the update
so usually what happens is when you try
with the default method or when you try
with the default codes or the commands
you might miss a couple of updates or
two or files right so what happens when
you try with the default codes or
default commences you might miss a file
or two so when you update the Ubuntu you
will get the missing files as well now
if in case if you find I've got all the
updates but in case if you find some
files are missing you might receive a
message from Ubuntu saying can't update
or not fetched right in that case you
can try upgrade command
even
then if you miss a couple of files there
is another similar command which says
sudo apt full upgrade we should also try
that as well
so basically what happens is you might
have one single command which says sudo
app install MySQL right so that
particular command will run but
unfortunately sometimes it misses to
face
complete get I mean it misses to get all
the files So to avoid that we will try
the brute force method which will get
all the files all the updates on all the
executable files you require to run
MySQL and Ubuntu right
just a couple of minutes yes
so similar to upgrade we have full
upgrade
it's done
and in case if you wanted to remove some
unnecessary files you have a command for
that as well so let's take a look at
that
so the sudo apt Auto remove will remove
any of those old packages which you no
longer need after the complete for
Library let's run that
there you go so now we are done with the
open to update let's clear the screen by
pressing Ctrl C shortcut with me
the shortcut key control L has been
press and the screen has been cleared
now now we are going to go with our SQL
installation command which is sudo APD
get installed
my SQL
yeah so again we Face some issues
regarding the installation so this means
that we might have some files which we
might not need related to mySQL so my
suggestion would be to eliminate those
particular files using the sudo app get
remove Purge MySQL server MySQL client
MySQL common yes
that is why so we're trying to remove
any of the existing files so let's again
let's try to get Auto remove
and auto clean
again the update
there you go we have the update and now
we shall try to install the MySQL server
with the following command but the
difference is we are trying to install
it with yes that is hyphen y
providing the permissions
there you go you can see my SQL is
running as
pid6045 anyways let's also check the
status once the update is done
there you go let's quickly check the
status by using pseudo system control
status MySQL
and there you go
it says the server is operational and
the main PID is
6240 let's quickly clear the screen
using Ctrl L key combination and now
let's start SQL by using the command so
do MySQL they should start MySQL for you
there you go that's how you install
MySQL and Ubuntu operating system again
you can run all your queries based on
MySQL and in case if you want to quit
just type in quit so to install SQL
server in Windows you will need two
different software packages the first
one being the SQL Server itself and the
second one is a SQL Server management
tool let's download these let's go back
to Google
foreign
server
download
now you can choose the first option SQL
Server downloads from Microsoft ensure
that you are choosing the software from
the service provider which is Microsoft
itself not the third party software
files
now if you scroll down you can see two
different versions of the SQL Server the
first one being the developer and the
second one being the express if you are
a learner then I would recommend you to
go with the express version because it
has more features than the developer
version and also it is open source now
let's go with the express version
download now
the software file should be downloaded
shortly
so we express the XE file has been
downloaded successfully click on it and
it should be running
now it is asking for the admin
permission get the admin rights and then
you should be good to go
once you provide the admin rights the
SQL Server installation will begin so
here you can see the window or the
dialog box which will give you three
different options basic
custom and download Media I would
recommend you to go with the basic
version
select that and now read all the terms
and agreements post that accept
and check the location where the SQL
Server is being installed if you're
comfortable with it you can click on
install or if you want to change go to
browse and select your folder I'm
comfortable with this particular
location which is program files so I'll
click on install
it should be installing in a while
there you go the download is successful
the installation phase might take a
little while
so the downward has been successfully
done and the installation has also
completed successfully now only the
first phase of the installation process
is done right the SQL Server is done but
we need another tool which is ssms or
SQL Server management story that you can
get right over here just click on
install ssmv and it will redirect you to
a different web page just click on the
web page you want to go or the web
browser you want to choose foreign
scroll a little
towards them and you can see the option
saying free download for SQL Server
management studio version
19.0.2 so you might be having the latest
versions in the future as well let's go
with the current version click on it
and there you go the system setup is
being downloaded here
it's 629 MB so it might take a while
there you go the Microsoft SQL Server
management Studio has already downloaded
and is being installed right now so now
you can see there is one bottleneck you
need to restart the system or you can
close and start it anyways but let's
choose the restart option
so after the restart the SQL Server
management studio is downloading a few
more packages and the installation
should be done in a while
there you go the installation has been
complete and you have the server
management Studio ready to execute open
that
so here you have the server type server
name and authentication if you want to
change them you can but I'm comfortable
with these and just press connect and
you should be good to go and get started
with you
query editor
then you can start writing your queries
on your SQL Server first let's
understand what is MySQL workbench or
MySQL workbench
so
MySQL workbench is a graphical tool for
working with mySQL servers and databases
you may use the MySQL workbench for
Server Administration for creating
entity relationship diagrams and for
running SQL queries
MySQL server is cross-platform meaning
that it can run on number of different
platforms such as Windows Linux Mac OS
and others
now
we will see the MySQL workbench
functionalities
so first we have SQL development or SQL
development MySQL workbench enables you
to create and manage connections to
database servers along with enabling you
to configure connection parameters MySQL
workbench provides the capability to
execute SQL queries on the database
connections using the built-in SQL
editor
next we have data modeling
the data modeling functionality of MySQL
allows you to create models of your
database schema graphically
reverse and forward engineer between a
schema and a live database and edit all
aspects of your database using the
comprehensive table editor the table
editor provides easy to use
functionalities for editing tables
columns indexes triggers partitioning
options inserts and privileges routines
as well as views
the third functionality is server
Administration
it enables you to administer MySQL
server instances by administering users
performing backup and Recovery
inspecting audit data viewing database
health and monitoring the MySQL server
performance
fourth we have data migration
now this functionality of MySQL
workbench allows you to migrate from
Microsoft SQL Server Microsoft Access DB
cybase SQL Lite SQL anywhere
postgres SQL and other relational
database management system tables
objects and data to mySQL
migration also supports migrating from
earlier versions of MySQL to the latest
releases
and finally we have MySQL Enterprise
support
the MySQL workbench has support for
Enterprise products such as MySQL
Enterprise backup MySQL firewall and
MySQL audit
now
let's have a look at the MySQL workbench
additions available to us
first we have the Community Edition so
this workbench Edition is open sourced
and can be downloaded free of cost
it came under the GPL license and is
supported by a huge community of
Developers
then we have the standard edition of
MySQL workbench
the standard edition of my S12 workbench
is the commercial Edition that provides
the capability to deliver high
performance and scalable online
transaction processing that is popularly
known as oltp applications
so the last addition that is the
Enterprise Edition we have is the
commercial Edition that includes a set
of advanced features management tools
and Technical Support to achieve the
highest scalability security reliability
and uptime
now this Edition also reduces the risk
cost complexity in the development
deployment and managing MySQL
applications
now with this theoretical knowledge
let's go ahead and see how to download
and install MySQL workbench on Windows
okay so I've searched for MySQL download
on Google and let me go ahead and click
on the first link which is from
www.mysql.com
this will lead us to the downloads page
I've opened in a new tab and in the
download section if I scroll down
you will find something called as
MySQL Community GPL downloads this GPL
stands for general public license which
is for free so we will install the
community edition of MySQL workbench
if I click on this it will take you to
another page where you have all the
MySQL Community downloads and here you
will find something called as MySQL
installer for Windows
I'll click on this
and here you can see we have the MySQL
installer 8.0 version
please go ahead and install from this
link you can just click on download
now we already have a video published on
how to install MySQL on windows so
please click on the above link to know
the steps for installation let me show
you the video so this is the video I'm
talking about which is already published
on our channel that is install MySQL
server and workbench on Windows all
right
now once the installation is complete go
ahead and launch the MySQL workbench so
here
in the search bar if I just type MySQL
you can see here I have the MySQL
workbench 8.0 version installed I'll
open this
so this is how the interface
looks like it says welcome to mySQL
workbench it tells you what MySQL is and
here I've already created a MySQL
connection now let me show you how to
create a new connection
I'll just click on this plus button and
it will open setup new connection
now here you can give a connection name
let me
type my name as MySQL underscore demo
now the connection method you can keep
it as standard TCP
now the host name will be the default
port number should be 3306 the username
I have kept it as root because this is
what I gave while installing
MySQL
if you want you can also set the
password
if I click on this you can enter
the password
I'll suggest you to give a strong
password I'll click on OK
and let's
try to test the connection
you can see here it says successfully
made the MySQL connection you have the
host the port number user and
it says
a successful MySQL connection was made
with parameters defined with this
connection just click on OK and I'll
click on OK again
you can see here we have made a new
connection which says MySQL demo
I'll click on this
and it will open my query editor
so let me open my MySQL workbench where
we will perform some Hands-On
demonstrations and look at how to use
MySQL functions write different commands
and we'll see the results
so here on the search bar I'll type
MySQL
so it says MySQL workbench 8.0 version
let me open it
okay you can see I have a
local instance connection I'll connect
to this
and I'll enter the password
so this is how my MySQL workbench
interface looks like let me just drag
this to the top
okay
now the white workspace that you see
here is called the SQL visual editor and
below
you will have the result Pane and the
history output window I'll show you once
I run a query and on the right hand side
you can see we have a help pin or a help
window
so if you want to
check the documentation
or the usage of a certain command you
can just type here and it will give you
the documentation as you can see I just
choose one command that is Select here
and it has returned me the syntax and
what select statement really does all
right
and here on the
left side you can see we have something
called Administration and schemas these
are the different databases that I've
already created so for this demo
we will start by creating a new database
so the command I'll write is create
database if I hit tab it will
autocomplete
and the database name I'll give us SQL
workbench
give a semicolon
I'll select this and you see this
thunder button if I click on this it
will execute my query
okay you can see here
it has returned me one row affected and
my query was successful
all right
now to move inside this database I'll
use
the command called use SQL underscore
workbench which is my database name
let's run this
you can see we have successfully entered
into our database now we can create any
tables perform any calculations
operations data manipulations retrieve
data of fetch data insert data and lot
of other operations
now under the schema let me just refresh
this so that you can see our new
database this is our database you can
see SQL workbench currently we haven't
created any tables if I
create a table it will show here you can
see here views stored procedures
functions and other things
so first let's get started by
looking at some of the numeric functions
that are available
in MySQL
so I am giving a comment by typing shift
and then my comment that is numeric
functions
first and foremost we'll see how to use
the absolute function in MySQL
so
for using the absolute function I'll
write select
abs
and inside this ABS function I'll pass
in a value let's say 22
now if I run this
it gives me a result that is 22 since
the absolute value of 22 is 22 because
22 we have passed in as a positive value
now let's say I'll pass in minus 22. and
let's run it
there you go you can see here
my absolute function has dropped the
negative sign and has written me a
positive value which is 22 you can try
for other values let's say I'll
select minus 50.
if I run this it returns me 50
all right
next
we'll see how
the mod function works
so the mod function Returns the
remainder of a division
so if I write select
mod
and I want to divide
10 by 4.
let's run this and see the result
you can see it has written me to
because the remainder for 10 divided by
4 is 2. you can also give an alias name
to this
I'll write as remainder
the reason why I am giving an alias name
is because
the result we have got you see the
column this is not very readable
now if I run this
you can see the difference there you go
now the output is much readable than the
previous one
okay so let's see
I want to find the mod of another
division 15 comma 3
as remainder again
I'll run it again
you can see 15 divided by 3 the
remainder is 0
let's try for one more let's say
50.6
divided by 2
you can already guess the result it
should be 0.6 there you go you can see
this is my
remainder
now as I said
the below window is called the history
output window or the pane and this is
called the query result pane
which is part of the MySQL workbench
let me just drag this a bit okay
now moving on to the next numeric
function we will explore the power
function
now suppose I write select
power
4 raised to 2.
let's see the result
I'll run it it gives me
16 which is correct
let's see
I'll write select power
10 raised to 3.
you can already
think of the result it should be 1000.
okay
now like how you
use the power function similarly you can
use the square root function in MySQL
the square root function is written as
sqrt
so you can
get the square root of a number by using
the sqrt function
let's say I want to find the square root
of 4.
if I run this
it gives me 2 which is the square root
of 4 I'll edit here itself let's say I
want to find the square root of 144.
where on this
it gives me 12 which is the
square root of 144.
now moving ahead
let's say you want to find the greatest
number within a range of numbers you can
use the greatest function that is
available in MySQL
I'll write select
greatest I'll give a range of numbers
let's say 2 5 18
6.
and let's say 12.
you give a semicolon and let me run it
it returns me 18 because 18 is the
largest of the greatest number
in my range of numbers
similarly you can also find the least
number for that you can use the least
function
this will return me the minimum number
present in my range of numbers in this
case it is 2. all right
there's another function that is
available in MySQL is truncate so the
truncate function truncation number to
the specified number of decimal places
so suppose I write select
truncate
22.897 comma 1.
let's see the output
okay you can see here
so the truncate function has returned us
22.8 and it has truncated the rest of
the decimal places
I want to truncate up to two decimal
places let's see the result again
you can see here it has given us 22.89
next
you have another function called round
so the round function MySQL is used to
round a number to a specified number of
decimal places if no specified number of
decimal places is provided to around a
function
the round of function rounds the number
to the nearest integer so let's see a
few examples
suppose I want to round the value 22.897
this time I am not passing
the specified number of decimal places
we'll see the result
it has returned me 23 which is the next
highest integer
suppose you want to
round it to two decimal places
we'll give a comma and then say 2
I'll run it it has given us 22.90
so this 8 9 it has converted to nine
zero similarly if you want to
round the number to one decimal please
it will give you 22.9
all right
now
let's create a student's table and store
it in our MySQL workbench
so I'll just give a
comment called student table or students
table
all right
so the way to create a table in a
database in MySQL workbench is you write
create table followed by
the table name that you want in this
case I am going to create a student's
table
then you start with parenthesis and
give the
columns that you want in your table
so first I want the student ID you can
think of this as the student rule number
give us peace and then give the data
type of the column now student ID should
ideally be of type integer I'm assigning
this as primary key
oh
so the primary key will uniquely
identify each record in a table
and it cannot have any
duplicate values
so ideally if you think all the students
in a school will have a unique roll
number
no two students will have the same roll
next column I want is the student name
now the name is of type worker
and I'll give the length as let's say 25
then I want the age of the student age
is also of type integer
and I'll write in the same line
then I need the gender
of the student should be of type
character and
the size I'll give us
one
then we have
DOA which stands for date of admission
and it is of type date
then we have the city to which the
student belongs to then city is also a
type
where care
all right you close the bracket and give
a semicolon let's run this
there you go here you can see in the
history window it says
the table was created successfully now
let's just refresh this again
so that you can see the table
here under MySQL workbench database
under tables you can see we have a
student's table let me expand this
further so that you can see the
columns that we have there you go we
have the student ID the student name
yield gender date of admission and the
City
okay
now it's time to insert a few
records to this table for that you need
to write the insert statement now I am
going to open a notepad where I have
already written the insert statement so
let me just copy paste it here
okay so here on my notepad I have my
insert statement already written I'll
just copy this and I'll paste it on my
workspace
OK if I go to the top you can see this
is how my insert into
command look like
you have insert into followed by the
table name which is students then you
have the values keyword and we have the
set of Records so the first
value represents the student
ID or the rule number then you have the
student's name you have the age you have
the gender then we have the date of
admission and then we have the city to
which the student belongs to
all right
now let me go ahead and run my insert
query I'll just select everything and
I'll hit on execute
you can see here you have successfully
inserted 20 rows of information to our
table
no
if you want to
check all the records in a table
the SQL command is Select start from
table name that is students
if I run this
this is my output you can see we have
the student ID the student name e gender
date of admission and City if I scroll
down there are total
20 rows of information in my table
now the star represents you want to
select all the columns in the students
table suppose
you want to return specific columns from
the table you can mention that in the
select statement itself
suppose I want to select the student
name the age of the student and the city
to which the student belongs to so I
will write select
Stu underscore name which is my column
name comma
the age
comma
the city
from my table name that is students
let's run it
you can see the output we have only
three columns displayed in the result
okay now
let's see how to use the where clause in
SQL or MySQL
so the where Clause helps you filter
specific records based on certain
condition
or conditions
suppose I want to see the students who
are from Pune so I want to
display only the records of students who
are from
Pune City so the way to do is I'll write
select
star from
students
where
City equal to
Pune
now this Pune is a
character type so you need to mention it
within single quotes
let's run it
there you go in the output you can see
there are total four students who are
from Pune you have Joseph
anubhav Akshay and Anand
all right
now
let's say you want to
filter only those students who are from
Miami and their gender is male
again you are going to use the where
clause and along with the where Clause
we will use the and operator
so I'll write
select
start from
students
where
CT equal to
I'll say Miami
this Miami should be within quotes
I'll use my and operator
and then write the gender should be
equal to
M or meal
again
M should be within single quotes I'll
give a semicolon and let's run it
you can see here
we have Whipple
ishan
tanishq and
Amrit who are from Miami city and that
gender is male
cool
now moving ahead
suppose you want to know the students
who are either from City Boston or
Chicago in that case you are going to
use an or operator
I'll just copy this
SQL command and I'll paste it here and
I'll edit in the same query so this time
we want the students who are from
City Boston or Chicago so here instead
of Miami I'll write Boston
I'll use an or clause or an R operator
and instead of gender equal to mail I'll
again write
or city equal to
Chicago
let us
run the SQL query and see what we have
so there are total
six students who are either from City
Chicago or from Boston we also have a
female student Eliana
all right
now moving further
let's say you want to
display the records of the students
who belong to any city rather than
Chicago
in that case you are going to use the
not operator
so I'll write select star from
students where
not City equal to
Chicago
let's run it and see the result
all right you can see total we have
returned 17 rows of information which
means
there are total 17 students who belong
to other cities apart from Chicago if
you see the result you won't find any
student who is from
Chicago City
okay
now there's another important
feature of MySQL where you can group
certain rows of information based on a
particular column or columns
so let's see how to use Group by in
MySQL
I'll give a
comment called Group by
now in this group by Clause we are going
to find the total number of students
present in each City
so the way to do is I'll write select
I want to select this city
and then I'm going to use the count
function this is an inbuilt MySQL
function
I am going to count the student IDs
I'll give an alias as
total students
from my table that is
students
then
I am going to group my result based on
each City
let's run this and see the output
there you go you can see here
so our table has total six cities you
have Pune New York
Miami Chicago Detroit and Boston and
here on the right hand side you have the
total students that we just created
using an alias name and this total
students column has the total number of
students from each City so if you see
here
New York has four students Pune has four
students in Miami Chicago we have four
and three students and in Detroit we
have two students respectively
all right
the next class we are going to see is
having
now having and where are kind of similar
but there are certain differences
now
for our example we are going to find the
cities where the total number of
students are more than three if you see
the results pin
so we have Pune we have New York and
Miami as the cities where there are more
than three students
so let me show you how to return these
three records so I'll write select
City
comma
I'll count
the students using the count function
and I'll pass my column as student ID
and I'll give an alias as total students
from
my table that is students
I'll use the
Group by Clause Group by City
and then I am going to use having
the count of
student ID
greater than 3.
let me run it and show you the result
there you go
as expected we have Pune New York and
Miami where the total number of students
are more than three
let's see
how the order by
Clause works
so the order by Clause is used to
filter the records based on a particular
order in ascending or descending order
so suppose
see I write select star from
students
and then I'll write
order by let's say City
let me show you the result first
okay you can see
the city column has been ordered in
alphabetical order
so first the city start with b then we
have c d m and then we have n and p
what if I want to order the resultant
descending order
so again it will
alphabetically sort my result in
descending order of City so
on the top we have Pune
because
alphabetically in descending order Pune
starts with p so it appears on the top
then we have New York followed by Miami
Detroit Chicago and Boston
now it's time to explore some string
functions in MySQL
so I have given a comment string
functions
first
let's say you want to convert a certain
string into upper case so I can write
select
the function I'll use is upper
and within this function you can pass in
the string let's say
I'll write India
if you want you can give an alias name
as let's say uppercase
I'll give a semicolon
and let's run it
there you go so my input was in sentence
case and using the upper function we
have converted everything into uppercase
similarly let me just copy this
and
I'll show you
if you want to convert a string into a
lowercase you can use the lower function
I'll run this you can see the result
everything is in lowercase now of course
I need to change the Alias name to
lowercase
instead of using lower as the function
there is another function that MySQL
provides which is called the L case
so I'll just edit this and write L case
and let's see I'll write India in
uppercase
let's run it returns me the same result
cool
moving on
let's say you want to find the length of
a string you can use the character
length function
I'll write select
use the function character length
and I'm again going to pass in my
string as India as let's say total
length
let's run it this time I'm going to hit
Ctrl enter to run MySQL command
there you go
it has given us the right result which
is 5 because India has five characters
in it
now these functions you can also apply
on a table
now let me show you how to do it let's
say we already have the students table
and you want to find the
length of
each of the student names
so here you can pass
Stu underscore name
and you can give the same Alias name
let's say total length
and then you can write from
table name that is students
if I run this
you can see the output it has given me
total 20 rows of information
it is not readable actually let me also
display these student names so that we
can compare their
length
all right
I'll run this again
and now you can
see the result so Joseph has six
characters nilis has six Whipple has
five anubhub has seven similarly if you
see Akshay has six then it has 7 Raga
was six
come in size 7 rabada has six so on and
so forth
now instead of using this character
length you can also use the function
car length
it will work the same way let's see the
result
there you go it has given us the same
result you can either use character
length or care length
foreign
function called concat so the concat
function adds two or more Expressions
together let's say I'll write select
use the function
concatenate
the function is actually concat
and I'm going to pass in
my
string values let's say India
is
in Asia
let's run this NCR result
you can see here it has concatenated
everything
let us make it more readable I'll give a
space in between so that you can read it
clearly
now this is much more readable India is
in Asia
and if you want you can give an alias
name as well as let's say merged
there you go
now the same concat operation you can
also perform on a table
I'm going to use the same students table
let's say I want to return the student
ID
followed by the student name
and then
I am going to merge
the student name
followed by a space
followed by the age of the student
and I can give an alias as let's say
name underscore each
from my table that is students
let's see how this works
okay you see here the result is very
clear
we have the student ID the student name
and the concatenated column that we
created which was name underscore each
where we have the
student name with a space followed by
the age of the student
so scroll down you can see the rest of
the results
cool
now moving ahead
let's see how the reverse function Works
in MySQL
so the MySQL reverse function returns a
string with the characters printed in
reverse order
so suppose I write select
reverse
I'll use the same string again let's say
I have
India
let's run it
you will see all the characters printed
in reverse order again you can perform
the same operation on
a table as well let's say I'll write
select
reverse
and I'll pass in the column as student
name
from my table that is students
let's run it
it gives you 20 students and all the
names have been
printed in reverse order
okay
now
let's see what the replace function does
so the replace function replaces all
occurrences of a substring within a
string within a new substring
so let me show you what I mean
I'll write select
replace
I'll pass in my input string which is
let's say orange is a
vegetable
which is ideally incorrect I am
purposely writing this so that I can
replace the
word vegetable
with
fruit
okay
so what this replace function does is it
is going to find where my word vegetable
is within the string my input string and
it is going to replace my word vegetable
with fruit
let's run it and see the output there
you go now this is correct which is
Orange is a fruit
all right
now
MySQL also provides some trim functions
you can use the left trim right trim and
just the trim function
so let me show you how this
left trim works
left rim or L trim removes the leading
space characters from a string passed as
an argument
so see I write select
I'll use the left trim function which is
L trim
and then I am going to purposely give a
few spaces
in the beginning of the string I'll give
a word let's say India
and then I'll give some space after the
bird India
and see how the
Ultram box if I run this it gives me
India which is fair enough
but before that
let's first find the length of my string
so I'll use my length function here and
within this function I am going to
find the length of my string which has
India along with some leading and
trailing spaces I'll paste this here
give a semicolon and I'll run it
okay so the entire string is
17 characters long or the length of the
string is
17. now see I use l trim on my same
string
what it returns me is India
and if I
run length over it you can see the
difference
as in you can see how many spaces were
deleted from the left of the string you
can see here now it says 17
and
I'm going to use l trim
let's see the difference it gives me 12
the reason being it has deleted
five spaces from the left you can count
it
one two three four and five so 17 minus
5 was
12 which is correct similarly you can
use the r trim function which removes
the trailing spaces from a string
trailing spaces are these pieces
when you use left Rim it deletes the
leading spaces which is this
now let me just replace L term with r
trim which stands for right trim and see
the result
so the length is 10 now the reason being
it has deleted
seven spaces from the right of the
string if you can count it one two three
four five six and seven
cool
you can also
use the trim function which will delete
both the leading and the trailing spaces
so here if I just write trim
and I'll
run it
it gives me five
because India is total five characters
long and it has deleted all the leading
and the trailing spaces
all right
there's also a function called position
in MySQL the position function Returns
the position of the first occurrence of
a substream in a string so if the
substring is not found with the original
string the function will return 0.
so let's say I'll write select
position
I want to find
where
fruit is
in my string that is
Orange
is
a fruit
I'll give an alias as name
the sum error here
it should be within double quotes
now let's run it and see the result okay
it says at the 13th place or at the 13th
position we have the word fruit in our
string which is Orange is a fruit
now the final function we are going to
see is called ASCII so the ASCII
function Returns the ASCII value for a
specific character let's say I write
select
ASCII of the letter small a
if I run this
it will give me the ASCII value which is
let's say you want to find the ASCII
value of
4.
let's see the result
it gives me 52.
all right
so that brings us to the end of the demo
session on MySQL workbench
let me go to the top and show you the
things that we covered so first of all
we created a new database called MySQL
workbench which you could
see it here under schemas there was
a database created called MySQL
workbench then we entered into the
database using the command use MySQL
workbench or SQL workbench we explored a
few numeric functions where we saw how
to use absolute mod power square root
least greatest truncate round
and then we created a table called
students we inserted some 20 rows of
information of different students and
their age date of admission City
we saw how to use where Clause how to
use the and and R operator
we used Group by to group our records
based on certain conditions we also used
having
we used order by and then we look at a
few
string functions such as lower upper
concat character length reverse replace
ASCII and position
all right
if you're an aspiring data engineer
looking for online training and
certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search number
simply learn Sports graduate program in
data engineering from Purdue University
in collaboration with IBM should be your
right choice for more details use the
link in the description box below
so what exactly are temp tables in SQL
so temp table is a temporary table so
the term temporary is self-explanatory
you know that every database and SQL has
tables right now let's say you created
10 tables in your database and you close
your MySQL workbench or you close your
database
and you restart it after a while and
then you will have all your 10 tables
intact in your database but temporary
table is not like that it is something
different which has its existence until
the session of the database is running
let's say you open the database now you
have this session of database running
you created the 11th table as a
temporary table and that particular 11th
temporary table will be existing in the
database only until the current database
is running and active once you close it
once you turn it off or once you restart
it the temporary 11th table that you
created will type or it will be
eliminated so that is the meaning of
temp table now let's see how we can
create a temporary table
so the syntax is completely similar to
the temporary or to the table what we
usually create right it is similar to
the table what we regularly create but
the only catches we will be using the
keyword temporary
create temporary table table name which
is user defined name and inside that the
parameters may be the employee ID
student IDM learning student ID name Etc
right so this is how we create the
temporary table now let's quickly get
back to the simple workwage and try to
create a temporary table add some data
into it and try to display the temporary
table if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scale up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now we are back on the SQL workbench and
meanwhile we are logging in
you might have a question right
when you say that the temp table will be
existing or running only until the
database is active then why create those
temporary tables in the workbench right
the sole purpose of using temporary
tables is
in a few cases the intermediate results
of the data analytics process are
important and you can have a quick
reference on intermediate results and
you don't want them to be existing in
your database in a permanent basis right
for such scenarios you can use a
temporary database now here on my
workbench we have a simple code for
creating a temporary table so I'll be
creating the temporary table on the name
of student and we have student ID
integrated by student name worker and
department and student ID will be the
primary key now let's use the database
that is used simply learn database to
get access and we have the access num
let's quickly see what and all tables we
have using the show command
show it's
enter
and we have two tables employee and
employee table 2 but not student
right now let's quickly execute this
control
enter
and now let's use the insert command
same like we inserted in the previous
tables insert into table name student
parameters ID name department and values
comma separated values student ID name
and departmental Group whatever he took
in college
right now let's execute this code
the data has been successfully included
now let's Select Staff from Sprint that
is view the contents in this particular
table we have the values in this
particular table and let's also see if
we have that particular data included in
the database or not let us show tables
there you go it's not included in the
database but it is active when you try
to you know print the values in that
particular table which is in the
database it will show you but when you
try to fetch that particular existence
or the permanent existence of that
particular table it will not be present
and this particular table will be active
only until the database is active now
let's restart this particular work which
I'm closing it
restarting it
now if I run this I will not get it you
can see the error the database
right okay then let's have the database
selected
and let's try to run the command
there you go
table simply learn DB dot student does
not exist
right
previously when you try to execute the
table was giving us values now we have
the error saying the table does not
exist right that is how a temporary
database runs SQL so first let's have a
quick look on the syntax we use to
create a database so first we have a
create keyword which will explain the
SQL Server that we are trying to create
a new element which can be a database or
a table next we have the keyword
database which clarifies the SQL that we
are trying to create a new database the
next one is not mandatory if not exist
just we are trying to make sure that the
database that we are going to create is
not already existing so if you use this
if not exist then SQL will tell you in
case if there is an existing database on
the same database name then it will not
allow you to create a duplicated
database and followed by that we have
the database name which can be anything
so I've just created as database name
here now that we are clear with the
syntax let's get back to to the IDE that
is MySQL to execute a command to create
a new database so now we are on the SQL
workbench now let's quickly try to login
there you go now you can see some
existing databases on the left hand side
of the workbench sys or system as the
default one so I already created test
and trial let's try to create a new one
right away
so the create keyword
database
keyword and then if not exists
so here you can see I'm trying to
capitalize the keywords so that it's
easier to understand what is the code
and what is the user defined names right
so create a database if not Xs and
simply done
DB
that's our code let's try to execute
this
and there you go so here you can see in
the action output create database F not
exists simply non-db has been executed
successfully now we can run a new code
which says show databases
this should show us the newly created
database which is simply learn DB which
is right over here so that's how you
create new database in SQL
now the syntax is as follows now here
you have the insert and into keywords
table name is the user defined name for
the table then you have the columns that
is column number one two and Etc then
after declaring the column names you
have the keyword values which will help
SQL understand this is a tuple and these
are the values involved inside the Tuple
that is Row 1 value 1 Row 1 value 2 so
on and Row 1 value n so this type of
syntax will help you to add one Tuple at
one time and this will take a lot of
time to process you can see to insert
the next apple we are writing a
completely new syntax once again using
the same insert into table name column
one two three and values and row number
two that is the second table right so
this type of code will take longer
duration to run as well as it will take
longer lines or number of lines will be
extra so is there a way where you can
add multiple tuples in one single curve
yes there is so the syntax will be
completely same right so you will be
using one insert into keyword one table
name and once you will be declaring all
the column numbers and once you will be
using the values keyword the only
difference is you will be adding
multiple tuples under the values bracket
right you will be declaring the number
of values you want to include in one
single go and this whole query becomes
as a whole and once you run this query
all the values will be added at once now
that you are clear with the syntax let's
quickly get back to the SQL workbench
and try to run this command
now we are on the MySQL workbench let's
quickly login
there you go we have logged in let's use
the simply learn database once again so
that we get access to the data which we
have so we already have an employee
stable
so let's see what's presently included
in employee stable select star
from employee
table
semicolon
so this is the data that we already have
in our table now let's try to add some
more data
so now we will include one single
element or one single Tuple data related
to one single employee right using the
first type of syntax let's quickly
execute this
the command got executed again let's
quickly see what's present in the table
select start
from
employee table again you can see I'm
using lowercase for the user defined
keywords and uppercase for the
predefined keywords just to make sure
that the code is understandable
and which is the user defined keyword
and which is the predefined keyword so
these are the the ones in small case are
user defined and the ones in uppercase
are predefined right so we have
successfully included one single element
or one single Tuple the details which
are related to Prime and now let's try
to modify the same code and try to
include few more tuples inside the same
insert command and try to insert
multiple rows into the table
now here you can see we are using the
same insert into employee table command
and instead of Brian we replaced or we
added six more entries under the values
section right and the only difference is
we are trying to separate the tuples
using a comma you can see we are
enclosing one Tuple inside the
parenthesis and we are separating two
tuples with the help of a Karma right
ensure that you include comma between
every Tuple and you can ignore the comma
for the last up you can see we are not
using any sort of comma or any sort of
specifier at the end right so and we are
closing the command using the semicolon
in this explains equal that it is the
end now we are going to run this command
and see the output
so there you go the command got
successfully executed now let's again
execute the select command and see if
the data is involved or included or
inserted into the given employee table
now there you go the command got
successfully executed and you can see
the table over here and you can see that
all the data or all the doubles we
included into the table using the insert
command in one go are successfully
included so that's how you insert
multiple rows into a table using SQL so
how to update table in SQL let's quickly
take a look on the Syntax for today's
function so here we have the update
keyword table keyword and the table name
which you want to update and followed by
that we have the set keyword which will
help this equal to set a particular
column name to a new parameter to which
you want to update it now you're giving
a where condition over here so where is
the keyword and the condition as a user
defined condition and the combination of
where and condition will help SQL to
identify a particular Tuple and update
the parameter under that particular
condition now that we have understood
the syntax let's quickly get back to the
SQL IDE which is MySQL workbench and try
to execute a sample command so we are on
the IDE and previously we tried to
create an employee table so let's select
the same table for that let's use the
database we created that I simply learn
DB semicolon enter so we are on the
simply on database now to update a table
we need to have some data in it so as we
remember we just try to create a normal
table in the previous session now let's
try to add some data into the same table
using the insert command so let's try to
make use of the insert command and
insert into is the keyword and clock
table is the table name and these are
the columns we have in the employee
table and followed by that we have the
values keyword and followed by that we
have the data which we need to enter
into the table and these items are in
the form of a tuple and every Tuple is
covered using parenthesis and inside the
tuples you have the first one which is
an integer type data which is as it is
and when you come into the text type
data they are covered using the single
quotes so let's equal identify that it
is a character type data now after
entering all the tuples separated by
comma we have a semicolon which
indicates the end of the statement now
let's try to run this particular
statement and add the data into the
employee table so let's select the
database once again and now let's try to
add the data there you go now we have
the data added onto our employer table
let's quickly check the employee table
select
start from
employee
there you go we have all the data added
onto the table employee ID employee name
and employee address let's say the last
employee Jeremy who's been working in
Delhi since a past couple of years and
you decide being the manager you decide
that he should be relocating to
Hyderabad and you need to update the
unplug table now by changing the
location of Jeremy from Delhi to
Hyderabad now let's try to run our
update query so first we have the update
keyword then employee
table
then
set
EMP address
equals to
Hyderabad
where
condition EMP
[Music]
ID
equals to
foreign
so there you go the code is complete we
have the update keyword followed by the
table name then set keyword to set that
particular column that is the employee
address to the key Hyderabad from Delhi
we are changing it to the Hyderabad
which is value or key value whichever
you consider and since it is a text type
value we are encoding it using the
single quotes then the weight loss and
the condition which is employee ID must
be equals to 1 0 0 6. now let's try to
quickly run this command
there you go now let's recheck if the
table has been updated or not so select
star from employee
table
let's run it
and there you go the last location
Jeremy which was Delhi is now updated to
Hyderabad so that's how you update
values in a table
now you might be having multiple
questions is adding a date is that tough
and SQL tables no you can add a date and
SQL in the format of worker or character
everything but if you want to perform
analytics then using the date format or
date data type would be more beneficial
right so for the SQL table you do have
some formats to follow so that's exactly
what we are going to discuss in this
particular tutorial now let us imagine
that we're going to create a table using
the following syntax that is create
table keywords table name which is a
user defined table name and the
parameters their respected data types
and at the end let's say we have a date
element as date of joining and for date
of joining we will have the data type as
date right then let's see the code
and you need to make sure that when you
are trying to enter the date element
into your table you need to be a little
more cautious to follow a pattern SQL
has predefined approach to store dates
which is in the format of YY here mm for
month DD for dates you need to follow
this particular way of writing your date
and if you make some minor at let's say
you add a date first then the month and
then the year then obviously SQL will
throw an error so we don't want that to
be happening so in that case let's try
to follow the approach that SQL has now
let's quickly go back to SQL workbench
and see how exactly it works so here we
are back on the SQL workbench let's run
this use database command to get access
to our database there we go now let's
see we have a freshly created database
and it doesn't have anything
right now we will add these particular
details into the data table and here you
see we are following the
year month and date approach right now
let's quickly run this command and there
you go the date has been updated into
the table let's now run the command
again now we have the dates here now
let's say we try to break the rules now
we will try the DD mm and the YY format
here right now let's try to run this
particular code once again so let's
eliminate all the previous elements
and let's consider this as a new entry
right now let's try to execute this
there you go so it will automatically
throw an error saying the date value is
incorrect you need to change this back
to the original form that is Wi-Fi month
and the date
only then it will accept this particular
value
there you go
so that's how you add date to your SQL
tables let's quickly take a look at the
syntax that we will be using today so we
will be using the alter keyword and the
table keyword followed by that we will
be specifying the table name in which we
want to add a new column then we have
the add keyword and name the column
which you want to add to your existing
table then the data type of that
particular column with constraints if
you have any now that we're clear with
the syntax let's get back to the SQL
workbench where we can execute this
particular command now we are on the SQL
workbench and let us execute this
particular command and see what we have
in our existing table okay I think we
might have to use this particular
command first you need to get the access
to your database then you can get access
to your tables in your database right so
we have this particular data let's try
to add a new column which explains about
the phone number of a employee working
in your organization
okay now we can use this particular
command which is called the table
there you go so we have added column
phone number data type and the
constraint not null and if anything is
not added in that particular column the
default value should be n a right let's
quickly execute this particular command
there you go now let's check if the new
column is added or Not by running the
cell command
there you go the new phone number has
been successfully added and by default
since we did not add any number we have
N A in that particular column so that's
how you add a new column to your
existing table in SQL how to change the
column name in SQL so let's quickly take
a look at the syntax that we will be
following to change the column name in
SQL so the syntax is as follows we will
be using the alter and table keywords
and we will be specifying the table name
and then we will give the rename column
keyword then the old existing column
name and to the new column in which we
need to change it to so having a clear
understanding of the syntax let's try to
execute this command in the Practical
mode so let's get back to the MySQL
workbench so now we are on the MySQL
workbench let's quickly get access to
the simply learn database
there you go and now let's quickly take
a look at the column names in our
existing table
now you can see the First Column is the
employee number let's try to change that
by using the alter table
command and then
and now the rename keyword
the column name is EMP number
two
EMP ID semicolon
let's quickly execute this command
there you go now let's try to execute
the select command once again and see
the output there you go now the employee
number has been changed to employee ID
so that's how you change the column name
in SQL
how to change the data type of a column
in SQL now let's take a quick look on
the syntax we will be using to change
the data type of the column in SQL
so this is a syntax we'll be using so we
will be using the alter keyword table
keyword and table name so Alta is the
keyword which will help SQL to
understand that we are trying to modify
something and we are selecting the table
by offering the table and then we have
the modify keyword which will help SQL
to understand that we are trying to
modify something and we are modifying
the column name from the table selected
and we are modifying that particular
column to a different data type which
will be specified over here in place of
data type keyword right so now that we
are clear with the syntax let's proceed
and execute the command and change some
column data types now we are on the SQL
workbench previously we created an
employee database in simply learn DB and
we will be using the same table here so
we will be typing use simply learn DB
so that we get access to the simply
learn DB and the tables we have there so
let's select all
employee table
column let's execute this
thank you
so there you go we have the table on our
screen and let's quickly describe the
table using the desc command
and this will give us the data types of
each and every column in our table now
you can see we have pin code in the
format of worker so let's try to alter
or modify this particular pin code
column from worker to integer since it
only saves the numbers right so our
Command for that was alter
table
table name which is employee table
modify with the keyword
modify the column PIN code
to integer
semicolon now let's quickly run this
command
and there you go the command got
executed successfully let's try to
describe the table once again
and there you go now the PIN code was
earlier mentioned as worker and now it
got changed it to integer now that's how
you alter or modify or change the data
type of a column in a table in SQL
now let's quickly take a look at the
syntax that we will be following to
execute this particular command
the syntax is as follows we will be
using the alter table keyword then the
table name we want to eliminate the
column followed by that the drop column
keyword and the column name now let's
get back to this equal workmans to
execute this particular command now here
on the SQL workbench and you can see we
have five different columns over here
and we have the phone number column
which does not have anything now we will
try to eliminate this particular phone
number column since we do not need that
for our purposes now the command is
really simple as discussed before we
will be using the alter table keyword
and the table name and the drop column
keyword and the phone number which is
the column name now let's quickly
execute this particular command and see
the output there you go now the column
phone number has been successfully
eliminated now let's run the select
command once again and see the new table
there you go the phone number column has
been successfully eliminated now with
that we have come to an end of this
session on how to eliminate a selected
column in an existing table in SQL
how do you delete a row and SQL let's
quickly take a look at the syntax
so we will be using the delete keyword
and the from keyword adding the table
name and giving a where Clause with a
user defined condition so this will be a
basic Syntax for the process of deleting
a single Row in the SQL table now to
understand in a much better way let's
get back to the SQL workbench so now we
are on the SQL workbench and previously
we tried to create table add some data
using the insert command and update a
value using the update command now let's
say we have to delete the last row which
is 1006 Jeremy Hyderabad let's say
Jeremy found a new job in a new
organization and now you need to
eliminate his credentials from your
database so we will be using the
following code
that is delete
from table name as employee
table
and the back loss
now the condition
which is
EMP ID
is equals to one zero zero six now let's
try to run the code
there you go the employee is being
eliminated from that particular database
now let's try to recheck the table
so select
star from EMP
loyee
okay
table
run the code and there you go the last
ID which was one zero zero six has been
eliminated from your database and that's
how you delete a row in SQL that is how
to print or how to obtain current date
in SQL now the syntax is really simple
we have two different commands to do
that we can just type in select get date
or we can just type in select current
date or Cur date so these particular
commands or functions will fetch as the
current date in SQL now to execute these
commands let's get back to the Practical
mode which can be a SQL workbench so now
we're on the SQL workbench let's login
there you go so we have both the
commands let's try to execute them
so enter and there you go so we have the
current date so that's how you can fetch
current date using get date function or
the current date function in SQL let's
try to take a quick look on the syntax
that we will be using today right it is
simply the Select Staff from table name
using the where clause and the column
which you're choosing for that and the
between operator and we are giving some
constraints and those different
constraints are encapsulated between an
and command here let us say that your
manager tells you to select all the rows
where selecting one single column that
is salary where the employees have the
salary from 10 000 to 20 000 right then
you will write the command select star
from table name with salary between the
value 10 000 and the value 20 000. so
this is how the between command works
now let's execute the same practically
let's get back to the MySQL workbench if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now we are back on the MySQL workbench
let's make some edits to the same
command select star from employee where
salary
between operator
so we are using floater integer type so
we will not need the single crochet
double quotes number 10 000
and operator number 20 000.
right now let's execute this command
there you go now we have all the
employer list which have or who have
their salary ranging from 10 000 to 20
000 now we can eliminate the duplicate
records in SQL by a few methods so we
will use the most simplest ones the
first one is using the inner join along
with the work loss and the second one is
a sample and the humble distance command
now we have a brief idea on the methods
let's understand them in a much more
detailed way through a practical
demonstration now let's get back to the
MySQL workbench to understand the codes
in a much better way so now we are on
the MySQL workbench and we will get
access to our simply learn database and
we are in the simply learn database so
previously we used to work on our
employee table so let's not work on the
same employee table since we have actual
data there let's try to duplicate that
table so that we will have some
duplicate entries in between so we will
be changing the employee ID numbers and
we will also be using the same employee
ID numbers so the employee ID has some
details to it so we'll be understanding
that in a much more detail while we are
executing the commands and we will also
try to remove the primary key from the
table so I'll also explain why we are
going to include the primary table and
also we'll explain the usage of
eliminating it so when you have the
primary key in the table SQL workbench
or any SQL will automatically stop you
from adding duplicated value yes but
let's say if you add a duplicate entry
with a new primary key right then it
will not stop you so we'll also have a
demonstration about what to do in such
scenarios so now let's try to quickly
create a duplicate employee table which
will be employed table 2 and then we
will try to add some duplicate entries
into it remember we will not use the
primary key here if the code will be
create
table
emply
ee table
two
and everything will be same which is
from the previous table which will be
the employee ID integer type employee
name character type this character type
pen code will be integer and normally we
include the primary key in this way
primary key brackets open
em
so this is the way how we add the
primary key but we are not going to add
it since we want to know what happens if
we enter data which also has the
duplication of the primary key right so
we will not give any primary key over
here
let's quickly run this
then I got the new duplicated table of
employee table has been created let's
try to insert the same values with some
duplication
there you go I have pasted the command
for inserting the values and if You
observe clearly at the end I have
repeated the values of Tony KT summer
June and Gloria so these five will be
the duplicate values and also we are
trying to enter the duplicated primary
key since we did not declare the ID as
the primary key it will accept all these
values let's quickly run this and there
you go the values have been successfully
entered into the table let's quickly see
if we have the duplication
select star
from
employee table
enter there you go so you can see the
duplicate values are also added onto the
table now how do you remove these
duplications remember we discussed the
distinct one distinct method which is
the second one so that happens to be the
most simplest one let's see how it works
so here we will write a simple select
command
select
distinct
star
from the employee table 2.
now this will give us the distinct
values
right but again when you run this
particular command which is Select star
you will have all the details back again
right our job is to eliminate them so
what we will do is we'll create a
duplicate table
so let's name it as the up table
so create table
duplicate table will be the name now
quickly execute this command
and there you go now we have
the
data
which we obtain from the distant command
is stored into the table named as
duplicate table
now let's quickly drop the employee
table 2.
okay the table has been successfully
dropped
so when we ran the same command once
again it says simply learned we did not
find any table by the name employee
tables too that means it's been
eliminated now the next thing we need to
do is rename it
so what we're trying to do is we are
trying to use the alter table and we are
trying to rename duplicate copy to
employee table 2 so that we have the
actual table here after eliminating the
duplicated values it's not to copy it's
actually Duke table
right
there you go
now let's execute this
successfully done now if we execute this
particular select command you can see we
have the cleaned data without any
duplicate entries this was one of the
simplest ways of eliminating duplicates
in a SQL table now let's try to get a
step ahead and try to use some join
commands and
where commands and where conditions and
using those we will try to eliminate the
duplications in a table now we are
talking about a table which does have
the you know primary key
and the datas will be duplicated let me
explain you how now let us that layer
the
primary key as employee ID
e
s e m p ID
right now we do have a primary key now
there is no way okay let's try to create
this before that let's try to truncate
employee table 2.
so we can use the
not the drop table we can use the
truncate so let's replace drop with
runki so that the data which we have an
employee table will be removed there you
go now
we will or let's quickly drop the table
because we are trying to create the new
table right so let's create the new
table
so once we have executed the drop table
command the table has been successfully
removed now let's try to create this
particular table
enter there you go 3 will got
successfully created now let's try to
duplicate the same entries remember I'm
not changing the primary key here
now when I run this command I will get
an error which says primary key cannot
be duplicated
so here you can see duplicate entry for
9 and you cannot have the duplicate
entries right this is one way to avoid
duplications but what if someone comes
up with a brilliant idea to replace the
primary key now if I change the primary
key
as
17 18.
let's say we also
have this data copy
let's duplicate
that right this will be our 19 and this
will be R20 now we have unique primary
keys for all our data and we also know
there are some duplications let's try to
execute this command and see the output
so somewhere something is not correct
yet
okay this one
so Tony has been repeated so we can have
a different ID for Tony
let's say we have Tony as 21
try to execute the command once again
it should be clear now
okay it still has some duplication
somewhere yes it's right here
let's keep this as 22.
okay I think we made a lot of
duplications somehow
let's quickly take a look if all the
major keywords are duplicated or not
so we copied from Gloria
so after Gloria we
we will remove these
so Gloria so we just make sure we're
trying to make sure that the primary
keys are unique here so 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20.
.
there you go so now we believe that all
the primary keys are unique let's try to
run this command and see if we get the
same error or not no so now all the data
has been inserted into the duplicate
table which is employee table 2 and we
also have some duplicate entries now how
would you recognize that we don't have
any duplicates or how would you
recognize which data has been exactly
duplicated and how do you even remove it
now the old distinct command is not
going to work
anyhow let's see if it works by any
chance so when I try to run the distinct
command it will give me all 22 rows with
all the duplicate entries right in this
case we can use the first method which
was the join and where condition method
right let's try to do that so we are
going to use the delete command
delete T1
from employee
table
to
T1
in a join
in a join employee table 2 as T2 so we
are declaring two different tables so we
are
considering T1 as one table and T2 as
the next or second table so T1 and T2
are the copies of the same existing
employee table 2 right now we are
joining these two tables and we are
having a fair condition over here so
from table T1 we're going to eliminate
table 1 from table two where we have an
intersection and where we have the
employee IDs greater than employee ID in
amplitude
okay let's not confuse so
let's execute the command first okay
let's
execute this to understand what I mean
here so here when we go a little down
you can see
14 for Tony right actual employee ID of
Tony is 9 but we have 14 for Tony and
Gloria we have 18 19 20 and again for
KTV we have 22 the actual number of KT
is
10 right so now it will try to recognize
the highest number of employee ID so it
will recognize the highest employee ID
number and it will retain it and rest
all the numbers will be eliminated so
this is the first where condition and
we're also giving a string comparison
function where SQL will try to identify
if there is a similarity between the
employee name of the first table and the
employee name of the second table and we
know that when you give the string
comparison operation if it results in 0
it means the strings are equal if it
results in 1 it means the strings are
not matching now that we understood the
logic of this particular statement let's
try to execute it
so there you go so we have executed the
command now let's try to see what's left
in the table there you go now we should
be having the usual 13 number of
employees in our table and you can see
that the records are retained where the
employee ID number is the highest
remember we had the number 10 as
employee ID for KD and we have that over
here in case if you want the actual
numbers to be placed however they were
you can make a small change to your
command all you need to do is keep this
particular or change this particular
greater than symbol to lower than symbol
and you will retain the actual numbers
of the employee records so that's how
you can eliminate the
duplicate entries in the table
and if you ask me
hey only two conditions are enough don't
you think the PIN code and you know we
also have PIN code and the address of
the employees don't you think that is
also important yes you can also do that
you can make some minor modifications to
your code and try to include all those
remaining things and again you can do
the same right now let's try to
eliminate the data in our table let's
truncate it and we should be having no
data left in our table and let's try to
insert the duplicate entries once again
and okay before that let's try to do
this particular execution remember we
tried to keep the employee ID let's try
to execute that and try to print it and
we should be having the actual numbers
over here right as expected
now let's again truncate the data and
try to compare the conditions or we will
be using the where condition and we'll
have all the parameters included in our
condition let's truncate the table and
let's try to add the duplicate entry so
once again
there you go we have all the duplicate
entries enter now what we will be doing
is we will be using the same command but
the only change will be the string
comparison or the where condition right
so you can keep this string comparison
if you want or if you can change that
let me change that actually
so insteader
yes we will use this particular command
where we are trying to compare the
employee ID so let's keep the employee
ID as
lesser than so that we have the actual
employee ID numbers and we are using an
and condition over here so that uh this
particular condition should be valid and
the employee name should be equal to the
employee name in T1 and T2
yeah and the the next one is here we
have the employee address so the
employee address in T1 and T2 should
also be same and pin code from both the
table should also be seen so what we are
trying to compare here is we are trying
to keep the employee ID with the least
number or the least value and the names
of the employee should be same the
address of the employee should be same
and the PIN code of the employee should
be seen in that particular condition you
can try to delete the record let's try
to execute this and there you go the
command got executed and now let's try
to execute the select command which
should give us the final result
so here you go control enter
and you have the data here so now we
have successfully eliminated all the
duplicates by comparing the values in
each and every single column and we also
have reading the original ID of each and
every employee now that's how you try to
eliminate duplicates in SQL tables so at
first let's take a quick look on the
syntax that we will be using for getting
the like operator operation
right so it's really simple so all you
need to do is Select star from table
name so instead of star you can also
give your selected columns here but by
default I'm using to select the entire
table right and it can go with a where
Clause so after the table name you will
be given the where clause and the column
name that you want to extract and you
will be using the like operator with the
constraints and I am using the single
quotes here right because this
particular like operation can be used
upon string or worker or character type
data types right so we will represent
that particular data type using single
code now that we are clear with the
syntax let's go to the Practical mode
that is the SQL workbench or MySQL
workbench and execute the like operator
command if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit skillup by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
SQL working
at the employee name so we have some
text or worker type of data type in the
employee name as well as the employee
Department right let's use that
particular data and here we have the
command and Select Staff from employee
table 2 where we can edit the same
command employee name
uh
like
and remember the single quotes right and
we will be using the percentage
operation here right we can give the
full name so we have Jennifer here right
Jennifer or let's remove Jennifer and if
somebody asks you give me all the names
which start with the G right in that
particular situation we will using the
modulus symbol or percentage symbol
right now what we will get is all the
names that start with the alphabet G and
now let's say we found all the names
that include a certain alphabet let's
say r
right then we can use the modulus symbol
again it can start with anything and it
can end with anything but it should have
alphabet R so this is how it works so we
have all the names which start or
include the alphabet are in them right
and that's how we can use the like
operator in SQL you can also use like
operator in this way where you can get
the entire name let's say somebody asks
you to get one single row which has the
employee name as beta right you can also
do this in this way
there you go you have Peter if you're an
aspiring data engineer looking for
online training and certifications from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search number one simply learns
postgraduate program in data engineering
from Purdue University in collaboration
with IBM should be your right choice for
more details use the link in the
description box below first
what is Group by in SQL so the group by
statement or Clause groups records into
summary rows and returns one record for
each group it groups the rows with the
same group by item expressions and
computes aggregate functions for the
resulting group
a group by Clause is a part of Select
expression
in each group no two rows have the same
value for the grouping column or columns
now below you can see the syntax of
group by so first we have the select
statement and Then followed by the
column names that we want to select
from we have the table name
followed by the where condition and next
we have the group by clause and here we
include the column names finally we have
the order by and the column names
now here is an example of the group by
Clause so we want to find the average
salary of employees for each department
so here you can see we have the
employees table it has the employee ID
the employee name the age of the
employee we have the gender the date on
which the employer joined the company
then we have the department to which
each of these employees belong to we
have the city to which the employees
belong to and then we have the salary in
dollars so actually we'll be using this
employee stable on MySQL workbench as
well
so if you were to find the average
salary of employees in each department
so this is how your SQL query with Group
by Clause would look like so we have
selected department and then we are
using an aggregate function that is AVG
which is average and we have chosen the
salary column and here we have given an
alias name which is average underscore
salary which appears in the output you
can see here
from employees and we have grouped it by
department so here in the output you can
see we have the department names and the
average salary of the employees in each
department
now let me take you to my MySQL
workbench where we will Implement group
buy and solve specific problems if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
okay so I am on my MySQL workbench so
let me make my connection first
I'll enter the password
so this will open MySQL editor
so first of all
let me
check the databases that I have
so I'll use my query that is show
databases
let's run it
okay you can see we have a list of
databases here I am going to use my
SQL underscore into database so I'll
write
use
SQL underscore intro
so this will take us inside this
database I'll run it all right now you
can check the tables that are present in
SQL underscore into database
if I write show tables you can see the
list of tables that are already present
in this database to do our demo and
understand Group by as well as having
let me first create an employee table
so I'll write create table
employees
next
I'll give my column name as employee
underscore ID which is
the ID for each employee
I'll give my data type as integer and
I'll assign
employee ID as my primary key
next I'll give employee underscore name
and my data type would be work r
I'll
give the size as 25
my third column would be the age column
age would obviously be an integer
then I have
my gender column
I'll use character data type and assign
a value of 1 or size of 1.
next we have the date of join
and the data type will be date
we have the
Department column as well this is going
to be of
and 20 will be the size
next
we have the city column
which is actually the city to which the
employee belongs to
and finally we have the
salary column which will have the
salary for all the employees okay
now let me select and run this
you can see here we have successfully
created our table
now to check
if our table was created or not you can
use the describe command
I'll write describe employees
you can see the structure of the table
so far
all right now it's time for us to insert
a few records into this employees table
so I'll write insert
into
employees
and I'll
copy paste the records which have
already
written on a notepad so let me show you
so this is my EMP notepad and you can
see I have already
put the information for all the
employees so let me just copy this
and
we'll paste it here
all right let me go to the top and
verify if
all the records are fine
all right
so let's run our insert query
okay so you can see here we have
inserted 20 rows of information
and
now let's check
the table information or the records
that are present in our employees table
I'll write select star from employees if
I run it you can see here
I have my employee ID the employee name
age gender
we have the city salary and in total we
have
instead 20 records
now
let me run a few SQL commands to check
how the structure of our table is
let's say I want to see the distant
cities that are present in our table
so I'll write select distinct City from
employees
if I run this
you see here there are total
eight different cities present in our
employees table so we have Chicago the
Seattle Boston we have New York
Miami and Detroit as well
now let's see
you want to know the
total number of departments that are
present so you can use distinct
Department
if I run this
all right you can see we have seven rows
returned and here are the department
names so we have sales marketing product
Tech I.T finance and HR
all right
now let me show you
another SQL command
now this is to use an aggregate function
so I want to find the average age of all
the employees from the table
so I can write select
AVG which is the aggregate function for
average
inside that I have passed my
each column from employees if I run this
so the average age of all the employees
in our table is 33.35
now
say you want to find the average age of
employees in each department
so for this you need to use the group by
clause
I'll give a comment here I want to find
the
average age
in each department
so
I'll write select
Department
comma
I'll write average of age
from
employees
Group by
Department
now if I run this
you can see here
we have our
seven departments
on the left and on the right you can see
the average age of employees in each of
these departments now you can see here
in the output it says AVG of age which
is not readable so I can give an alias
name as
average age
all right
I can bring this down
and if you want you can round the values
also
so you can round the decimal places so
I'll use a round function before the
average function
and the round function takes two
parameters one is the variable and
the decimal place you want to round it
to
so if I run this there you go you can
see here we have the average each of all
the employees in each of these
departments
all right
now suppose you want to find the total
salary of all the employees for each
department so
you can write select
Department
comma
now I want the total salary so I'll use
the sum function
and I'll
pass my column as salary
from
employees
Group by
Department
let's run this query
you can see here
in the output we have the different
departments and on the right you can see
the total salary of all the employees in
each of these departments now here also
you can give an alias name as
total underscore salary
let's run it again
and you can see the output here
all right now moving ahead
you can also use the order by Clause
along with the group by Clause let's say
you want to find the total number of
employees in each City and group it in
the order of employee ID so
to do this I can use my select query
I'll right select
count of let's say employee ID
and I want to know the city as well
from
employees
Group by
City
and next you can use the order by clause
I'll write order by
count of
employee ID
and I'll write desc which stands for
descending
if I run this query
you can see here on the left you have
the account of employees and on the
right you can see the
city names so in Chicago we had the
highest number of employees working that
was four then we had Seattle Houston
Boston Austin
and the remaining also had two employees
so in this case we have ordered our
result based on the count of employee ID
in descending order so we have the
highest number appearing at the top and
then followed by the lowest okay
now let's explore another example
suppose we want to find the number of
employees that joined the company each
year we can use the year function on the
date of joining column then we can count
the employee IDs and group the result by
each year
so let me show you how to do it
so I'll write select
I am going to extract here from
the date of join column I'll give an
alias as year
next
I'll
count the
employee ID
from my table name that is employees
and
I am going to group it by
year
date of join
I give a semicolon
all right
so let's run this
grid you see here in the result we have
the year that we have extracted from the
data join column and on the right you
can see the
total number of employees that joined
the company each year so we have in 2005
there was one employee similarly we have
in 2009 there were two employees
if I scroll down you have information of
other years as well
now if you want you can order this as
well based on year or count
okay
now you can also use the group by to
join two or more tables together
so to show you this operation let me
first create a sales table
so I'll write create
table
sales
and the sales table will have columns
such as the product ID which is going to
be of integer type then we have the
selling price of the product
now this will be a a float value
then we have the quantity sold for each
of the
products so I'll write
quantity
quantity will of integer type
next we have the state in which the item
was sold
and state I'll put it as worker and give
the size as 20.
let's run this so that we'll create our
sales table all right
so we have successfully created our
sales table
next we need to insert a few values to
our sales table so I have already
written the records in a notepad let me
show you
okay so here you can see I have my sales
text file let me just copy these
information
I'll just paste it on
the query editor
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this
insert command all right so you can see
here we have successfully inserted nine
rows of information so let me just run
it through what we have inserted
so the first
column is the product ID column then we
have the selling price at which this
product was sold then we have the
quantity that was sold and in which
state it was sold so we have California
Texas Alaska
then we have
another product ID which is one two
three
and these are the states in which the
products are sold
so let me just
confirm with the
select statement I'll write select star
from
sales
where on this you can see we have
successfully created our table
okay
now suppose you want to find the revenue
for both the product IDs one to one and
let's say one two three since we have
just two product IDs here
so for that you can use the select query
so I'll write select
product ID
next I want to calculate the revenue so
revenue is nothing but selling price
multiplied by the quantity so I'll use
the sum function to find the total
revenue
and inside the sum function I'll use my
selling price column
multiplied by
quantity column
I'll give this
an alias name as Revenue
from
my table name that is sales
finally I'll group it by
product ID
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
the two product IDs one two one and one
two three and here you can see the
revenue that was generated from these
two products
all right
now let's see
we have to find the total profit that
was made from both the products one to
one and one to three so for that I'll
create another table now this table will
have the cost price of
both the products so let me create the
table first
I'll write create table
let's say the table name is C product
which stands for the cost price of the
products
I'll
Give My First Column as product ID
this will be an integer
and I'll have my second column as cost
price
cost price will have floating type
values
let's run this so we have successfully
created our product cost table
now let me insert a few values into the
C product table so I'll write insert
into
C underscore
product
I'll give
my values
for one to one
let's see the
cost price was 200 and
70 dollars
for each
and next we have my product is one two
three and let's say the cost price for
product one two three was
250 dollars
let's insert these two values okay next
we'll join our sales table and the
product cost table so this will give us
the profit that was generated for each
of the products
so I'll write select
C Dot
product underscore ID
comma
I'll write sum
s dot cell underscore price now here C
and S are Alias names
so if I subtract my
cost price from the selling price that
will return the profit that was
generated
I'll multiply this with s dot
quantity
close the bracket
I'll give an alias name as
profit
from
seals as s
so here s stands for the sales table
I'm going to use inner join
C underscore
product table
as
the Alias name should be C
where
s dot
product underscore ID is equal to C Dot
product underscore ID we are using
product underscore ID because
this column is the common column to both
the tables
and finally
I am going to
group it by
C dot product underscore ID
all right
so let me tell you what I have done here
so I am selecting the product ID
next I am calculating the profit by
subtracting the cost price from the
selling price and I have multiplied the
quantity column
I'm using an inner join to connect my
sales and the
product cost table
and I am joining on the column that is
product ID and I have grouped it by C
dot product ID let's run this there you
go so here you can see for product ID
one to one we made a profit of
eleven hundred dollars and for product
ID one two three we made a profit of
eight hundred and forty dollars so now
that we have learned Group by in detail
let's learn about the having clause in
SQL the having clause in SQL operates on
grouped records and returns rows where
aggregate function results matched with
given conditions only
so now having and where Clause are kind
of similar but where Clause can't be
used with an aggregate function
so here you can see the syntax of having
Clause you have the select statement
followed by the column names from the
table name then we have the WHERE
conditions next we have the group by
finally we have having and at last we
have order by column names so you can
see here we have a question at hand
we want to find the cities where there
are more than two employees
so you can see the employee table that
we had used in our
Group by Clause as well so if you were
to find the cities where there are more
than two employees so this is how your
SQL query should look like so we have
selected
the employee ID and we are finding out
the count using the count function
next we have selected the city column
from employees we have grouped it by
City And then we have user having clause
so we have given our condition having
count of employee ID should be greater
than 2. so if you see the output we have
the different city names and these were
the cities where the
count of employees was greater than 2.
all right so let's go to our MySQL
workbench and Implement how
having box so suppose
you want to find those departments where
the average salary is greater than 75
000 you can use the having clause for
this so let me first run my table which
is employees
if I run this you can see we had
inserted 20 rows of information and
the last column we had was salary so the
question we have is we want to find
those departments where the average
salary is greater than 75 000 dollars
so let me show you how to do it
so I'll write
select
Department comma
I'll use the aggregate function that is
average
salary
I'll give an alias name as
AVG
underscore salary
from
employees
next we'll use the
Group by clause and I want to group it
by each department
and then I am going to write my having
Clause so in having Clause I'll use my
condition that is having
average of salary
greater than
75 000 dollars
let's run it
and see the output there you go so here
you can see there were total three
departments in the company that is sales
finance and HR where the average salary
is greater than 75 000 dollars
okay
next let's say you want to find the
cities where the total salary is greater
than two hundred thousand dollars
so this will again be a simple
SQL query so I'll write select City
comma I want to find the total salary so
I'll use the sum function
and I'll pass my column as salary as
I'll give a
Alias name as total from
employees
Group by
City
and then I am going to use my having
clause
I'll pass in my condition as having
sum of salary
greater than
two hundred thousand dollars
all right
so let's run this query
there you go
so
so the different cities are Chicago
Seattle and Houston where the total
salary was greater than two hundred
thousand dollars now suppose you want to
find the Departments that have more than
two employees so let's see how to do it
I'll write select
Department comma this time since I want
to find the number of employees I am
going to use the count function I'll
write count Star as
employee underscore count or EMP
underscore count which is my Alias name
from
employees
next I'll group it by
Department
having
I'll give my condition
count star greater than 2.
let's run this
okay
so you have departments such as sales
product Tech and it where
there are more than two employees
okay now you can also use a where Clause
along with the having clause in an SQL
statement
suppose I want to find the cities that
are more than two employees apart from
Houston
so
I can write my query as select
City comma
count star
as
EMP count
from
employees
where
I'll give my condition shitty
not equal to
Houston I'll put it in double quotes
since I don't want to see
the information regarding Houston
I'll group it by
City
having
count
of employees greater than 2.
so if I run this query
you see we have information for Chicago
and Seattle only
and we have excluded the information for
Houston
now you may also use aggregate functions
in the having Clause that does not
appear in the select clause
so if I want to find the total number of
employees for each department that have
an average salary greater than 75 000 I
can write it something like this
so select
Department
comma
count
star
as
EMP count
from
employees
Group by
Department
and in the having clause
I am going to provide the column name
that is not present in the select
expression so I'll write having
average salary
greater than 75 000.
this is another way to use the having
Clause let's run this
all right you can see we have department
sales finance and HR and you can see the
employee count where the average salary
was greater than 75 000.
okay
so let me run you from the beginning
what we did in our demo so first we
created a table called employee then we
inserted 20 records to this table
next we explored a few SQL commands like
distinct then we used average and
finally we started with our
Group by clause
followed by
looking at how Group by can be used
along with another table and we joined
two tables that was sales and product
cost table to find out the profit
then you learned how to use the having
clause
so we explored several different
questions and learned how to use
having an SQL
now before we execute the actual code
let's take a quick peek on the syntax
that we will be using today now the
syntax is completely similar to the
regular syntax that we usually use but
we'll have the select keyword parameters
that you want to print in your table the
from keyword and the table name which
you are trying to access the only
difference is you will have a new
keyword that is the group by keyword and
based on a certain parameter right now
we would get back to the Practical mode
that is the MySQL work means to
understand the practicality of group by
clause in a much better way if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now we are on our SQL workbench now
let's get access to our simply on
database there you go now let's quickly
take the look at the tables we have we
have two different tables now let's get
access to our
employee table
now we have all the employee numbers
employee names Department designation
salary Etc right let's say you wanted to
know the average salary of all the
employees right so that would be select
that is the AVG
average function of salary
plus a bracket from
employee right
let's execute this
there you go now you have the average
salary of the entire office but what
happens when your manager asks you to
find the average of each and every
Department average salary of the
employees in each and every Department
how would you do that
right every organization has multiple
departments HR development testing etc
etc right now your manager wants the
individual Department's average salary
then you can use this particular clause
which says Group by department so the
entire table will be categorized based
on the Departments and it will be
grouped on the basis of the department
and I'm also using the order by here
which we will discuss in the next
session but to give you a brief
understanding of why we're using order
by let's say your manager asks you to
find the department which has the
highest average salary right then you
will be ordering the tables or ordering
the rows based on the descending order
of the salary now let's quickly execute
this query and see the output there you
go the query got successfully executed
and we have the average salary of each
and every Department it's how to find
the second highest salary in SQL so this
particular type of questions will be
most frequently Asked in data analytics
interview questions so let's try to
understand the syntax of how to find the
not just second but any number of
salaries given in a SQL table let's say
your interviewer asked you to find the
top third salary or top fourth salary
you can find that using the same syntax
so the syntax is something similar to
this as shown now but before we begin if
you are an aspiring data analyst then I
have the perfect cause for you we have
the professional certificate program in
data analytics both your carrier over
this data analytics program in
partnership with Purdue University and
in collaboration with IBM which features
master classes and follows an applied
learning model with real-time projects
and business case studies now that we
have a clear understanding of the pgp
data analytics certification with simply
learn in collaboration with IBM from
Purdue University we will get started
with our tutorial for today's session
so here you can see select star you can
also use these specific columns you want
that is name and salary but I'm
selecting star that is every single
column in my table that is Select star
from employee table Group by salary so
you'll be grouping by salary here and
order by salary descending since we
wanted to find the highest we will be
choosing the descending order that is
increased number that is the highest
number to the lowest number in case if
your employer or if your interviewer
asks you to find the lowest salary then
you will be using the ascending order
right so since we are given the
condition that we have to find the
highest we will use the descending order
then limit n minus 1 let's say You're
supposed to find the fifth highest
salary then the formula will be 5 minus
1 and the limit one that is you just
want one single row to be displayed on
your output right so that's the reason
we'll be giving limit as one right so
this is the simple syntax you will be
following now let's quickly execute this
on MySQL workbench and try to get our
results
back to the Microsoft SQL workbench so
now we are on the MySQL workbench let's
quickly use the database and get access
to our all tables now we have access to
the tables and the employee table which
we were working on
so let's quickly have the show tables
here and
we have employee and employee table 2 we
will be accessing the employee table
which has the salary details so there
you go we have Rakesh Jack Regina Etc
right so here you can see Karen has the
highest salary and the next second
highest salary is Rajesh so we need to
fetch this particular column here right
since our expectation is to find the
second highest salary let's try to
write the following code that is Select
star from employee
Group by
salary
earned by salary
descending order since we want highest
salary and the limit
n minus 1 that is 2 minus 1 or you can
also write as 1 comma 1. and done
and let's quickly execute this code and
there you go now let's say we want to
find the third highest salary so here n
minus 1 3 minus 1 is 2
and execute this
and there you go you have Regina so
that's how you can extract second
highest salary or any number of highest
salary of the lowest salary based on the
query changes you're doing let's say if
you want the highest salary then you
should be using descending order let's
say you want the lowest salary should be
using the ascending order so that's how
you can extract the second highest
salary from SQL tables how to create
views in SQL
if you are an aspiring data analyst
looking for online training and
certification from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading industry experts then search no
more simply launch professional
certification program and data analytics
from Purdue University in collaboration
with IBM should be your right choice for
more details use the link in the
description box below with that in mind
go to our PPT now how do we create a
view in Excel so it's as simple as
creating a new table the syntax is as
follows you just need to add create a
view and your customized view name as
the statements now what are the
statements statements usually have the
statements of what you quoted the query
statements for example select start some
data what you want to fetch from your
table
yes I totally understand select might be
a really short one but sometimes you
might have to add some wear conditions
you might have to add some sub queries
and the entire query length might go up
to 10 to 15 lines
right now you might not be able to
execute that query for every single time
so if you create a view for that and if
you just write select that particular
View and you get all the data now let's
understand this more easily by going
through a practical demonstration on
MySQL now we are on the MySQL workbench
we are having a small database which is
flights and in that we have a table by
the name slide data and this is the data
which we have added into a flight data
right let's run this and get the table
so here you have the information on your
table about a few flights you have the
airline date of Journey departure
destination total stops additional
information
etc etc right now let's say if someone
asked you to fetch a flight from Indigo
which is completely Non-Stop
control enter now you have this right
now you finish this query for once and
what if someone asks you to get this
data for 10 times a day maybe you have
10 clients who are asking for the same
information would you write this thing
for you 10 times
no right similarly here you have let's
say someone wanted to go to Delhi and
they asked you to get information for
the flights which are going to Delhi
and someone asked for the flights which
are going from Bangalore to Delhi
right similarly you have many of such
things so what would be helpful here so
let's say you add one more query
which reads as
create
View
now the customized view name could be
anything let's say View
Indigo Non-Stop
as
your query
right let's quickly execute this query
and it should create a new view for you
the new view is currently done
similarly let's try to create a new view
again
create a view let's name it View
lights
Delhi
Kolkata
and the Bangalore daily flights
right now you have the queries ready
or the views ready
now all you have to do is just get the
select statement
star from the view name
this is simpler right
it's Ctrl enter and you have the data
over there now let's say somebody asks
you to fetch the data for flights from
Bangalore to Delhi all you have to do is
Select star and you should be having the
data
there you go right as simple as that so
that's how you can create a view in SQL
and in case if you wanted to drop it
let's say you don't need it anymore so
it's simple just drop the view
and the view name let's say you want to
drop this particular View
paste it there and Ctrl enter there you
go the view got successfully dropped now
when you try to run this query you will
not get it as simple as that
now I'm sure you must have heard about
databases but mongodb is a popularly
used not only SQL database
now without further delay let's begin
and understand what exactly mongodb is
so here's what's in store for you first
we'll understand what mongodb is
then we'll understand why exactly
mongodb is used
then we understand the characteristics
of mongodb
after that we'll understand the working
of mongodb and how it functions we'll
also look at some of the commonly used
applications of mongodb and finally we
look at the top companies that readily
deploy mongodb so what exactly is
mongodb
it is a document oriented nosql database
it was initially released in August 27
2009.
mongodb replaces the concept of rows of
conventional relational data models with
something called documents it offers
developers the flexibility to work with
evolving data models since its document
based mongodb allows embedded documents
arrays and represents complex
hierarchical relationships using a
single record it is also schema free
which means that the keys defined in the
document are not fixed as a result
massive data migrations can be ruled out
but you must be wondering when there's
something like SQL why is nosql or
mongodb used
there are a few reasons why mongodb is
widely used
first up is flexibility
mongodb's notion of documents that can
contain sub-documents nested in complex
hierarchies is really expressive and
flexible
flexible query model a user can
selectively index some part of a
document or a query based on attribute
values regular expressions or ranges
next up is native aggregation native
aggregation allows its users to extract
and transform data from mongodb and
either load them in a new format or
export it from mongodb to other data
sources it makes it extremely compatible
lastly as mentioned earlier the schema
free model now applications get the
power and responsibility to interpret
different properties in different ways
now that you know what mongodb is and
why exactly it's used let's have a look
at the characteristics of mongodb
firstly it's a general purpose database
now mongodb can serve heterogeneous
loads and multiple purposes within an
application
again it has a flexible schema design
document oriented approaches with
non-defined attributes that can be
modified on the Fly is a key contrast
between mongodb and any other relational
database
next up is scalability and load
balancing it's built to scale both
vertically but most importantly
horizontally using sharding an architect
can share load between different
instances and Achieve both read and
write scalability
when it comes to load balancing this
happens automatically and transparently
to the user by the sharp balancer
again we have aggregation framework now
mongodb offers an extract transform and
load framework that eliminates the need
for complex data Pipelines
native replication now data will get
replicated
across a replica set without complicated
setup
security features both authentication
and authorization are taken into account
in mongodb
next up is Json now Json is widely used
across the web for front-end and API
communication and as such it's easier
when the database is also compatible
with the same protocol
lastly we have mapreduce now again
mapreduce is an excellent tool to build
data pipelines and mongodb uses
mapreduce readily now let's quickly have
a look at the working of mongodb
data is stored in documents with the
help of key value pairs now the data is
stored in the bson format at the back
end mongodb converts Json data into a
binary format known as bson
mongodb also makes provision for nested
data now all of these documents are
stored in a collection these collections
hold multiple documents and since
mongodb is schema less the documents in
one collection need not be similar now
again these collections are stored in
the entire mongodb database as mentioned
earlier mongodb makes provision for
nested data this makes fetching of data
extremely efficient when compared to
other databases now you must be
wondering where exactly mongodb can be
applied or used so let me help you with
that several areas of Technologies use
mongodb as their dbms currently some of
them are Internet of Things mobile
applications real-time analysis
personalization catalog management and
content management
now all said and done let's look at some
of the companies that use mongodb
currently
companies like Toyota sap AstraZeneca
Adobe Verizon Cisco Barclays and Google
among others readily deploy mongodb as
their database management system how to
basically install momodb
inside your MacBook
many people today use MacBook and
there's a common question we receive
like how to do the necessary setup it is
very simple first of all you have to go
back to your terminal
okay and inside this terminal to just
type the command name called
preview
a space update
number one
in case
if you do not have a preview I would
like to request you that new
first of all try to install the preview
first
okay so make sure that you install the
query first and in case if you do not
have the success or the privilege
available to you so you first use pseudo
command before to make it possible
okay number one so you have to just say
preview update
well next step all the blue update is
happening Next Step will be you have to
do the same command called sudo in case
if you do not have a privilege we can
use sudo space Brew
a space
install space
mobile
DB okay so blue install mongodb that is
the first commandment to type it
once you say will install mongodb the
mongodb will get installed in your
system it will take some time depends on
your internet speed once it is
downloaded then in Next Step all you
have to do you have to basically go back
and create a new folder where because
it's since it is a nosql database so it
has to have some folder in which
you have to provide the location where
the data will get stored
so after downloading you have to create
a DB directory
this is where the files or the
mongodata files will actually stay you
can create this directory in the default
location by running this called mkdir
okay space hyphen p
and say slash data slash DB
I'll be clear
and also you have to make sure that you
have the proper write permission because
in MacBook this is one of the very very
common challenge
okay you do not have a permission so
make sure that the data DB have a
correct flight permission so in order to
do this you have to use this command
called sudo
space
okay see you soon and after that you
will say hyphen R and then
you have to use ID space hyphen even
okay and then you have to use slash
so like this you will be in position to
give the permission so It'll ask you the
password post that you have to give the
password whatever the password of your
MacBook it is
and that's it
and once it is ready
your mogodb is all set
and to start this memory
or mongodb you have to start the mongod
as a server so if I just have to start
so you have to start with this
okay
I'll be clear now so mobile D then after
up to you iPhone hyphen DB bar
after that you have to give the standard
sign slash data slash TV
you hit enter and you can see now your
mobile database is now starting up that
is now waiting
for your
client to get connected to so you
have to open the other terminal
parallely
I'm saying
new tab
and here we are just typing
and there we go you are connected
successfully
just type show DBS
anywhere done so friends it is a very
simplified way of how the mongodb can be
installed into your MacBook very very
simplified steps I told you there are
other options are also available but
this seems to be more better
you will have to navigate to the
official mongodb website
and here you can see
software
so go ahead and click on community
server under software
and you can see that the current version
is 4.4.4 and the platform is Windows and
make sure that the package is MSI all
right now go ahead and press download
so this could take a while
all right so once it's downloaded
go ahead and install it
now since it's already installed on my
system uh the installation process will
be different but you just need to follow
the steps there and finally install it
so once you're done with the
installation you can go to your C drive
and here you can click on program files
and you can see that mongodb is
installed and inside of it you have the
server folder and then you have the 4.4
folder and then you have the bin folder
right so here you have the application
that is your and the mongod
applications both are executable files
now the mongod file or the application
is the Daemon process now this is the
background process that makes sure you
retrieve the data from the database
access the data so it does all the
background tasks so after the
installation now you need to create a
path to this file by doing this you
don't have to always go to the bin
folder and then execute the file you can
directly execute the file on your
command prompt right so for that let's
just
go to our environment variables
but before that let's just uh
copy this path
right
and here under the user variable section
click on path and say edit
and go ahead and just paste it right
I've already pasted mine so just go
ahead and paste it and click on OK
and
say okay
right so now you've created the path
successfully now let's head to our
Command Prompt and run the file so
here you can just directly type
since the path's already been created so
just go ahead and say
[Music]
and here you can see that your
server has been generated
and with this you know that your in
mongodb has been successfully installed
and your server is up and running right
so just for confirmation let's see if
there are any databases and how much
space they've occupied so you can right
now just type show DBS
[Music]
and when you click on it it says admin
config and localhost and all of it is
zero so with that you have successfully
installed mongodb on your system and
it's up and running
now we have moved to something called
very important that is installing
mongodb on Linux this demo will show the
steps to install mongodb on Linux 64
plate
so what's we're gonna do
this command will download the mongodb
from the internet
so this command is gonna enter the
downloaded mongodb which we have done as
you can see we can see the bin
we're creating a directory called
mongodb
foreign
of the mongodb
to The Bash RC file so that I can
execute mongodb bin from wherever I want
it's like and one variable setting the
way we do for javafa.net in Windows we
have environment variables similarly in
Linux we have the bashashi files
so that is how the
installation will happen of
mongodb on Linux system and now we will
see how the mongodb gets installed on
the windows so this is something which
again I would really uh want all of you
to really focus on
it's again simple the same way as we did
in Linux
so what we do is so we have mongodb
installation going on so what I do okay
so I'm again talking about Windows and
would recommend if all of you also
follow the same so first step is
download
you will get some dot zip version
second step
or rename
it as mongodb so again I'm telling you
the
scenarios so that everyone can go along
and place it under C
place it and the C you can place it
anywhere again for better
let us keep it in the C so now I'm
assuming all of you have your mongodb
under I'm assuming your mongodb will be
over
okay this will be a folder inside this
you should be able to see bin now
and the bin should have all of the
different commands
now what I would recommend is instead of
just double click in mongodb open a
command prompt
open
a command prompt
go to
see
mongodb bin
go to this path
up till the bin and now when you are in
the bin
type
mongod
and put an enter
it means you're saying that start the
database instance you should see
on the screen you should see on the
screen
waiting
for
connections
to open
on the port
this is what you should see on the
command prompt
fifth step
open
another command prompt
go to
see mongodb
and type
and put an enter
now what you should see in the current
your current command prompt should tell
should say
connected
to test
and your
previous command prompt
that is on the step four
should now say
one
Connection open
okay so this is what your scenario
should be so please all of you follow
these steps if you're an aspiring data
engineer looking for online training and
certifications from the prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns postgraduate program in
data engineering from Purdue University
in collaboration with IBM should be your
right choice for more details use the
link in the description box below
mongodb is a document-based database
the basic idea behind shifting from
relational data model to a new data
model is to replace the concept of a row
with a flexible model the document the
document based approach allows embedded
documents arrays and represents a
complex hierarchical relationship using
a single record
this is how developers using
object-oriented languages want to
represent their data mongodb is schema
free the keys used in documents are not
pre-defined or fixed without a fixed
schema massive data migrations have
become unnecessary
while migrating data to mongodb any
issues of new or missing keys can be
resolved at the application Level rather
than changing the schema in the database
this offers developers the flexibility
of working with evolving data models
the table given on the screen depicts
the various SQL terminology and Concepts
and the corresponding mongodb
terminology and Concepts
in mongodb the table and view structure
is known as collection
typically these Collections Group
documents that are structurally or
conceptually similar
mongodb allows embedding of related
document to one another
these documents are used to query
related data the data for a table in
mongodb are distributed among different
shards which is similar to the concept
of partition in relational database
Management systems or rdbms
after grouping structurally similar
documents into collection
mongodb groups different collections
into databases
for instance a single instance of
mongodb is capable of Hosting multiple
independent databases
ideally you should store data related to
a single application at one database
you need separate databases when storing
multiple application or users data on
the same mongodb server
the data model in mongodb is document
based although documents provide Rich
structure they need not conform to any
pre-specified schema
in a relational database rows are stored
in a table and each table has a strictly
defined schema that specifies the
permitted types and columns if a row in
a table requires an extra field the
entire table needs to be altered
mongodb on the other hand groups
documents into collections that do not
follow any schema each individual
document in collection can have a
completely independent structure
in practice documents in a collection
are relatively uniform
for example if you are creating a
collection review underscore comments
for storing review comments given by the
customer then every document in this
collection will have Fields such as
title tags comments and so on
the lack of schema offers many
advantages
first since structure is defined by the
application code not the database this
speeds up initial application
development when the schema tends to
change frequently
second a schema-less model lets you
represent data with variable properties
compared to rdbms such as MySQL which
supports two-phase commit mongodb only
supports a single phase commit at each
document level
a write operation in a single document
is considered Atomic in mongodb even if
the operation Alters multiple embedded
documents however the entire operation
is not Atomic and other operations May
interlave
some of the key features of mongodb are
as follows
ad hoc queries
mongodb allows performing of search
functions by field range queries and
regular expression searches
queries can return specific document
fields and may include user-defined
JavaScript functions
querying for document retrieval mongodb
uses Rich query language it also allows
you to write any complex condition to
retrieve documents fast In-Place updates
mongodb allows you to choose write
semantics enable journaling and thus
control the speed and durability
All rights are sent across a
transmission control protocol or TCP
socket and do not require a database
response
to get a response use the special safe
mode of the drivers and perform a write
this generates a response acknowledging
the receipt of the right with no errors
server-side JavaScript execution
mongodb uses JavaScript inquiries and
aggregation functions such as mapreduce
which are sent to the database for
execution
capped collections capped collections
are fixed size collections supported by
mongodb these collections maintain
insertion order and once the specified
size has been reached behaves like a
circuit or Q
ongodb supports other data types while
retaining json's essential key value
pair characteristic
how values of each type are represented
depends on the language used
following is a list of the commonly
supported data types null is used to
represent both a null value and a
non-existent field for example field X
has null value
undefined is used in documents
JavaScript has distinct types for null
and undefined for example field X is
undefined
Boolean is used to represent true and
false values for example field X is a
Boolean variable whose value is true
32-bit integer cannot be represented on
the shell
JavaScript supports only 64-bit floating
Point numbers hence 32-bit integers will
be converted to 64-bit
64-bit integer the shell cannot
represent these and will display them
using a special embedded document
64-bit floating Point number
all numbers in the Shell must be of this
type
here are a few more data types supported
by mongodb
maximum value
Basin contains a special data type that
represents the largest possible value
the shell does not support this type
minimum value
Beeson contains a special data type that
represents the smallest possible value
the shell does not support this type
object ID
object ID data type is unique fast to
generate and ordered these consist of 12
bytes where the first four bytes
represent the object ID creation time
string Beeson strings are utf-8
compliant typically when serializing and
deserializing Basin programming
languages convert language strings to
utf-8 format this allows easy storing of
international characters in bees and
strings
symbol symbols are not supported by the
shell when the shell gets a symbol from
the database it converts it into a
string time stamps Basin offers a
special timestamp for internal mongodb
use that is not associated with the
regular date type
note that within a single mongod
instance timestamp values are always
unique
date
date and Beeson is a 64-bit integer that
denotes the number of milliseconds since
the Unix epic it can represent a date
range of about 290 million years into
the past and future
regular expression documents contain
javascript's regular expression Syntax
for example
X is the field whose value contain
substring simply learn
following are some more data types
supported by mongodb
code documents can contain JavaScript
code for example logic inside function
binary data it is a string of arbitrary
bytes it cannot be manipulated from the
shell
array sets or lists of values can be
represented as arrays
courses is the field whose value is an
array this array holds three elements
PMP cloud and mongodb
embedded document
documents can contain entire documents
embedded as values in a parent document
for example course underscore duration
is the embedded document which has field
name mongodb the value for this field is
24 hours
the core database server of mongodb can
be run as an executable process called
mongod or
mongodb.exe on Windows
the mongod process receives a command to
run the mongodb server over a network
socket through a custom binary protocol
the data files for a mongod process are
stored by default in the directory slash
data slash DB
you can run a mongod process in several
modes the most common mode is the
replica set typically replica set
configurations comprise two replicas and
an Arbiter process that reside on a
third server
the auto sharding architecture of
mongodb consists of mongod processes
configured as per Shard replica sets it
also consists special metadata servers
called config servers
in addition s a separate routing
server is used to send requests to the
appropriate Shard s queries from
the application layer and locates the
data in the sharded cluster to complete
these operations a s instance is
identical to any mongodb instance
mongodb tools consists of the following
JavaScript shell database drivers and
command line tools
the Java Script shell the command shell
in mongodb is a javascript-based tool it
is used to administer the database and
manipulate data a executable loads
the shell and connects it to a specified
mongod process
in addition to inserting and querying
data the shell allows you to run
administrative commands
database drivers
the mongodb drivers are easy to use
it provides an application program
interface or API that matches the syntax
of the language used while maintaining
uniform interfaces across languages
10gen a company behind mongodb supports
drivers for C C plus plus C hash erlang
Haskell Java Perl PHP python Scala and
Ruby
command line tools mongodb contains the
following command line utilities
mongodump and restore are standard
utilities that help back up and restore
a database
mongodump can save the data and the
Beeson format of mongodb and thus is
used for backups only this tool is used
for hot backups and can be restored with
restore easily
export and import are used
to export and import Json comma
separated value or CSV and tab separated
value or tsv data these tools help you
get data in widely supported formats you
can use import for initial Imports
of large data sets however you need to
adjust the data models for best results
in such a case you can use a custom
script to easily import the data through
one of the drivers
sniff is a wire sniffing tool used
for viewing operations sent to the
database
this tool translates the Beeson that is
transmitted to human readable shell
statements
stat is similar to iostat
mongostat provides helpful statistics
including the number of operations per
second for example inserts queries
updates deletes and so on
it also provides information such as the
amount of virtual memory allocated and
the number of connections to the server
this demo will show the steps to install
mongodb on Linux
in this demo you will learn how to
install mongodb on Linux machine
first download the latest mongodb binary
for Linux platform
to download type the command shown on
the screen
after the mongodb binary is downloaded
untot by executing the command shown on
the screen
next create a directory slash mongodb by
executing the command make directory
hyphen P slash mongodb
next copy the untarred directory by
executing command shown on the screen
to run mongodb from anywhere in Linux
you need to add mongodb installation
path in the dot bash RC file
to do so execute the command v i space
slash root slash dot bash RC
next type the two commands given on the
screen
note that your dot bash RC file location
may be different based on your username
and profile
reload the environment variable by
executing the command Source slash root
slash dot bash RC
next execute the command Echo dollar
mongodb underscore home to verify
whether the environment variable mongodb
underscore home has been set or not
this concludes the demo on installing
mongodb on Linux computer
this demo will show the steps to install
mongodb on a Windows computer in this
demo you will learn how to install
mongodb on a Windows computer
mongodb 4 Windows runs only on Windows
Server 2008 R2 Windows Vista or the
later versions
the dot MSI installer includes all
software dependencies
if you have an older version of mongodb
installed on your computer the dot MSI
file will automatically upgrade it to
the latest version
to install first go to the site given on
the screen
in the download and run mongodb page
scroll down and click download to MSI
and then click run
once the MSI file is downloaded the
installation wizard opens automatically
next follow the default options on the
wizard to install mongodb
this concludes the demo on installing
mongodb on a Windows computer this demo
will show the steps to start mongodb on
Linux in this demo you will learn how to
run the mongod server and the
shell on Linux
to start the mongod server type mongod
in the command prompt the mongod script
file is in the slash bin directory of
your mongod home path
once mongod server starts running open
another terminal
to open the shell type in
the second terminal
in the shell perform the mongodb
insert operation by executing the
command given on the screen
to check whether document was inserted
use the find method on courses
collection
this concludes the demo on starting
mongodb on Linux this demo will show the
steps to start mongodb on Windows in
this demo you will learn how to run
mongod server and shell on Windows
machine
to begin navigate to The Path C colon
backward slash program file slash
mongodb slash server slash 3.0 slash bin
to start the mongod server double-click
mongod.exe
once the mongod server starts running
open another command prompt to open the
mongod shell
to open the shell double-click the
mongo.exe in the same directory
to perform the insert operation in the
shell execute the command given on
the screen
to check whether the document was
inserted execute the command DB dot
courses dot find
this concludes the demo on starting
mongodb on Windows something which used
to happen earlier and it
and I didn't think it gave way to
something called replica sets so the
Master Slave replication is the oldest
mode of replication that mongodb
supports in the earlier versions of
mongodb the Master Slave replication was
used for failover
backup and the retailing in the new
volumes it is replaced by replica sets
for the most number of use cases here
you can see there is a master and there
are slaves attached to that so replica
sets are recommended for new production
deployments to replicate data in a
faster than a Master Slave
architecture
so again how does a replica in mongodb
works so a replica set consists of a
group of mongodb instances that we just
saw that holds the same data set that
again we saw the replica set functions
is followed the primary mongodb receives
all the right operations and the
secondary mongod replicates operations
from the primary this is something which
Sandeep would have seen in a live I'm
working on his replica set the primary
node receives the right operations from
the clients the primary logs any changes
or updates to data sets in its AppLock
the secondary is replicate the op log of
the primary and apply all the operations
to their data sets
so replica set in mongodb
an extra mongodb instance can be added
to a replica set to act as an Arbiter so
what is an Arbiter node so this is
specifically added to the replica set so
that you know the total number of uh
instances we can have a can be odd so
that if in case if the primary goes down
we can have a majority if an election
takes place so following are some of the
characteristics of an Arbiter so
Arbiters do not maintain a data set
Arbiter is the node we just participate
in an election to select the primary
node so the only purpose of it is to
take part in the election it doesn't
even store the data so again orbitals do
not require radicated Hardware again it
can just work as a command prompt you
know as we have done in our systems
secondary members in a replica set or
synchronously apply operations from the
primary important point to be noted over
here is Earth synchronously it's a lazy
right
these replica sets can function without
some secondary members as a result all
skin remembers may not return the
updated data to the clients so again
when I told Sandeep that you know you
make a right to the primary or an update
to the primary and see the data back in
the secondary so you guys would have
seen again that you know you are not
able to see the data over there in the
secondary it'll come after some time
because again it's a lazy ride to the
secondary
so a primary can convert to a secondary
or vice versa however an Arbiter remains
changed
automatic failover so there's something
which talks about the replication in
detail and what it talks about is when
the primary node of a replica effect
stops communicating with other members
for more than 10 seconds another member
is selected as the new primary
selection happens through an election
process the secondary note that gets
majority of the votes becomes the
primary a replica set supports
application needs in the following ways
again deploying a replica set in
multiple data centers
manipulating primary election by
adjusting the priority of the member so
that's what again when we initiate an
instance I can also when I specify the
config I specify the config again ID the
members along with that I can specify
the priority as well that you know if
the priority of the guy will be more I
can ensure that whether the secondary
will be able to become a primary ever or
not
supporting dedicated members for
functions such as reporting Disaster
Recovery or backup so again we can see
in the diagram that another primary goes
down what happens is election for a new
primary happens and again we see that
you know the new primary is elected one
of the secondary becomes the primary and
the other secondary just follows what
the primary shares
again the application members a replica
set can also have a arbiter Arbiters do
not replicate or store data but again
play a crucial role in selecting a
secondary to take the place of a primary
when the primary becomes unavailable a
typical replica set contains a primary
secondary and an Orbiter so again what
we see is we have a primary node we have
a secondary node and we have an Arbiter
and you can see there is a heartbeat
going constantly between all the nodes
again this heartbeat is on similar lines
in our heartbeat we see in Hadoop in
Adobe we see all the secondaries that is
the data nodes you know
share a heartbeat with the name node so
again like this all the nodes over here
in mongodb as well
share a heartbeat among themselves
an application in mongodb version 3.0
can have maximum 50 members with only
seven members capable of voting in the
election
so okay now we are specifically talking
about who our priority is zero
replication members again when we set a
member a priority of zero what will
happen that will become a that will be a
secondary which can never become a
primary so again a priority zero member
is a secondary member that cannot become
the primary the characteristics of a
priority zero are it cannot trigger any
election
it can maintain data set copies except
and perform read operations and again
choose in electing a primary so again he
can vote an election though he cannot
trigger an election
so by configuring a priorities you
remember you can prevent secondaries
from becoming the primary in a
three-member replica set
one data center hosts both the primary
and the secondary and a second data
center hosts one priority zero member so
again you know I've just kept one copy
of the data in some other data center
just to ensure if the full data center
goes off I still have some data with me
safe in some other Data Center
a priority zero member acts as a backup
and can immediately replace an
unavailable member in a replica set
because again it has the data so always
we recommend that you know we have a
priority zero uh a replica set member as
well in our replica set
now we have something called hidden
replica set members again hidden members
of those which are not you know seen to
the client what again that means hidden
members of a replica set are invisible
to the client applications the
characteristics of a hidden member are
restore a copy of the primary's data
their priority zero members again they
mean thermody sheep right is zero the
main thing which should come to your
mind is it's a secondary and it cannot
ever become a primary their priority
General members can elect a primary but
cannot actually become a primary or
replace a primary they're not given
appropriate read and write rights they
can be used for dedicated functions like
reporting and the backup so there's
something you see there is a primary
there is secondary secondary secondary
and again there is a secondary drivers
priorities
then there are some you know replicases
again an important thing which you know
is asked in the interviews quite often
for a delayed replica set members again
I can even set some members in a replica
set with a delayed you know I can
specify that you know you copy you start
copying the data from the primary after
these particular minutes so those are
called delay replication numbers
so again delayed replication members are
secondaries that copy data from the
primary nodes AppLock file after certain
interval or delay delayed replication
members reflect a previous version or
delayed state of the store data set it's
like you know I create a backup of the
data after every some T hours what
happens is in case of a failure or
something I can again make the system
come back from whatever time it was
earlier
so delayed replica asset members are
secondaries that copy data from the
primary nodes of log file after certain
interval delay delayed replicated
members reflect the previous version or
delay Etc state of the store data set so
again uh what I was saying to you guys
was very importantly they are basically
used so that you know we can a
checkpoint you know some data so that if
in case of some failure I can still
bring the data back to the system to the
place it was earlier
so delayed members perform a role backup
or on a historical snapshot of the data
set they help manage various human
errors and recover from errors such as
unsuccessful application upgrade and
drop databases and collections
the characteristics of a delayed member
are as follows it must be a priority
zero member it must be hidden and not be
visible to Applications it again must
participate in electing a primary now
again we can see over here what is this
so what we're talking about is you can
configure delete you can remember with
the seconds given below so okay delete
sync and remember it again has to have a
priority value of zero which again means
that it is a secondary which cannot ever
become a primary hidden value is true it
means it'll be hidden and again slave
delay value means again how much seconds
you want the system to wait till it
mates
a copy of the op log to set an one hour
delay issue the operations given below
again you can see over here what we are
setting is we are setting a
configuration so config is equal to
rs.com
and again what we give over here is
config members zero dot priority we are
giving a zero again members so again
please see that you know what you see
over here the members
the members you see over here is the
array which you had in your
configuration
so the first member his parade team
setting is zero his hidden and setting
is true his slave delay I'm sitting here
3600 and again after I made some
configuration changes I can reconfigure
first let's look at what exactly is
mongodb
now as you all know mongodb is an open
source document oriented nosql database
it is document based which means that
the data stored is represented in a
hierarchical relationship using a single
record
and also mongodb is schema free which
means there's no set schema to Define
how the data is being stored in the
database this causes lesser data
migrations but what exactly is MySQL
then
now MySQL is an open source relational
database management system unlike
mongodb which is document oriented MySQL
is a relational database system now this
uses something called as a structured
query language and this is used to
access data which is stored in the form
of rows and columns now as mentioned
earlier data here is stored in the form
of tables with rows and columns and each
data field comes with an index
representing the data in the table
and SQL is developed and maintained by
Oracle
so then what exactly sets them apart so
in the coming section we look at some of
the differences between MySQL and
mongodb depending on certain features
first up is the data structure
now MySQL requires you to Define your
tables and columns before you can store
anything and every row in a table must
have the same columns
in mongodb you just drop the data in
these documents also the data and the
mongodb database is stored in a binary
format called as bson next up we have
schema now as discussed earlier MySQL
requires a set schema to define the
tables in the database now the database
administrator is requested to define a
schema which defines how the different
tables are being stored in the database
now this schema is crucial in case of
MySQL on the other hand mongodb doesn't
require a prior definition of a schema
next up is languages
MySQL uses the structured query language
to perform actions on the database it is
used to retrieve data add data update
create a new data set Etc in case of
mongodb it supports a Json query
language to work with data next up is
foreign keys now MySQL supports the
usage of foreign Keys now if you don't
know what exactly your foreign key is
then SQL uses foreign keys to link one
table to another now these foreign Keys
make data retrieval easy especially when
there are multiple tables interlinked
with one another in case of mongodb
there's no support for foreign keys
next up is replication now MySQL
supports the Master Slave and the master
master application in this setup data
set from one master database server can
be copied to other servers
in case of mongodb
it uses something called as sharding now
sharding allows partitioning of data
across multiple servers using a Shard
key don't worry if you're not able to
understand these Concepts well in the
coming videos we'll explain these
Concepts in detail
next up is scalability now SQL database
can be scaled vertically while mongodb
can be scaled both vertically and
horizontally now horizontal scaling
means scaling by adding more machines to
your pool of resources while vertical
scaling refers to scaling by adding more
power like for example CPU or Ram moving
ahead let's look at performance now
MySQL is optimized for high performance
joins across multiple tables while
mongodb is optimized for write
performance
talking about Community Support some of
the popular GitHub repositories and
MySQL currently are MySQL JS MySQL and
then there's MySQL server and at the
time of writing there were about 222
000 repositories on GitHub with 7
million comments for MySQL in case of
mongodb a few popular GitHub
repositories are mongodb and
Doctrine mongodb and at the time of
writing there were about 177 000
repositories with about 923 000 comets
according to Google Trends MySQL is
largely used compared to mongodb
so now the question arises which one
should you choose
well if your application requires multi
row transactions like for example in
accounting system then a relational
database would be more ideal
but if you're using mongodb then it is
more suitable for real-time analytics
content management Internet of Things
mobile applications and so on also MySQL
is a great choice if you have structured
data and need a traditional relational
database
in case of mongodb it is an ideal choice
if you have an unstructured set of data
so you could pick your choice and if
you're partial towards one dbms let us
know in the comment section below as to
why you like that particular dbms and
with that we have reached the end of
this session on the entire SQL and
mongodb Basics fill course should you
need any assistance based on PPT project
code or any other resources used in this
session please let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts would be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe keep
learning and get ahead stay tuned for
more from Simply learn staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here